So, gerade aufgestanden, zuerst mal die T-Ringe, exellent, warten bis Twitch gecheckt hat,
dass der Stream online ist, in der Zwischenzeit zeige ich euch mal meinen Desktop, ich weiß
der Chat mag ja meinen Desktop, moin, den haben wir da, TheTV, morge, exellent, kurz was
T-Ringe, ich war übrigens immer noch nicht auf Fiverr und habe Emotes gekauft, unbedingt,
ich muss unbedingt meine 22 Emote-Slots voll machen, der Desktop ist der beste, deswegen
zeige ich den auch immer, weil ich weiß der Chat mag den Desktop so, deswegen habe ich
jetzt extra ein bisschen rangezoomt, dass der Chat noch mehr Spaß an meinem Desktop
hat, normalerweise sieht der Desktop so aus, was natürlich gleich viel besser ist.
Okay, guck mal hier ist doch Platz, seht ihr das, da ist Platz, da ist Platz und da ist
das, HW, was ist das, was haben wir da gemacht, ach das ist wo wir die CPU und Grafikkartentemperatur
Overlay programmiert haben, ich kann mich gerade erinnern, alles der unso nixen Sachen,
da wollte ich einfach nur wissen wie es geht, brauchen tut man es nicht, tut man es nicht,
da ist für die Klimaanlagensteuerung, kann man löschen, habt ihr gesehen Windows lag
sogar, wenn man Sachen vom Desktop löscht, habt ihr es gerade gesehen, ah ne okay jetzt
geht es, so Events gibt es auch gerade keine, die haben wir alle schon durch, ist irgendein
neues Apple Event oder so in nächster Zeit, Apple, Nvidia, AMD, die haben wir alle schon,
zumal als egler Weihnachten ist wahrscheinlich eher nicht, Cyberpunk kommt raus jetzt gerade,
wenn ich das richtig mitbekommen habe, ähm, hat die GameStar schon Cyberpunk Review, Cyber,
das interessiert mich der Foto Modus, der Foto Modus könnte mir nicht egaler sein, gibt
es da schon irgendeinen, das ist doch, heute Nacht war doch Release oder, äh, heute Nacht
nicht Release, bin ich das durcheinander, ach am 10. erst, achso, was war denn, ach heute
Nacht gab es den Pre-Load, kann das sein, irgendwas war heute Nacht habe ich gelesen,
noch mal, ey das war jetzt, das war jetzt die übelste Troll Aktion, Cyberpunk Yellow
Background, so, das ist ja schon zu meme schlecht hingeworhen, jeder der irgendwie lustig sein
will posten sowas mit dem Yellow Background, ok, dauert noch 3 Tage, na gut, dann, dann
noch 3 Tage, Musiks, oh nee passt eigentlich von der Lautstärke her, so, was ist denn das,
ist das, ok, das ist 9 Sekunden und das wird, das wird Safe for Work sein, Moment, was,
ist das wirklich aus dem Game, what the fuck, wirklich, perfect, what is das wirklich aus
dem Game, nennt man das, nennt man das beim Kegeln, nennt man das beim Kegeln, wenn man
alle wegkegelt, Coq, das nennt man so, genauso wie die Cola, Coq Frau, das ist auch so unglaublich
uralte, weiß nicht, wie ich da drauf jetzt komme, jetzt wird es gerade in Verbindung
dazu, ich find das gerade so in den Kopf, was ist das an Schwachsinn, vor allem YouTube,
warum wird es mir jetzt empfohlen, warum hat sich YouTube gedacht, ah ja, ja Moment, da
heute Morgen, das müssen wir dem Max unbedingt nice Coq empfehlen, hör dir mal an wie die
Japaner Google aussprechen, keine Ahnung, Guggele, Guggele, ich weiß es nicht, Guggele,
ich weiß es nicht, wie die das aussprechen, ich weiß nur, dass die Christmas sprechen
sich ganz merkwürdig aus, Krishmasse oder so, Krishmasse, ganz merkwürdig, die machen
ja gerne im japanischen, wenn die ausländische Wörter haben, machen die halt am Ende noch
irgendwie ein Vokal dran, dann wird auch Heatpipe, da ist ein E hinten dran, dann wird Heatpipe
zu Heatpipo, oder Hitopipo wird es dann, Hitopipo, hat der Typ gesagt auf der Playstation 5
Presentation, Hitopipo, ja aber warum uns jetzt YouTube gerade nice Coq empfehlen hat,
weiß ich auch nicht, der bisherige Erfolg von Amazon Game Studios, ja nichts, das gab
ja nicht viel, es gab diesen komischen Overwatch oder was auch immer es sein soll, Overwatch
clone, den sie ja quasi direkt nach Release gesagt haben, A geht zurück in die Beta,
A ist eingestellt, und dann haben sie noch ihr MMO, was anscheinend ganz ok wird, bin
ich mal gespannt, und ansonsten, ja, hält sich in Grenzen, fällt mir jetzt nicht so
viel ein, was hat denn Amazon Game Studios schon tolles gemacht, oh die haben ja tatsächlich
noch mehr gemacht, ah ja Apple, nicht Apple, App Dinger für Mobile Kram, gut das ist jetzt
nicht so, nicht so spannend, genau Crucible, null, was war denn das gesagt, das kenne ich
noch nicht mal, ok auch alles gecancelt, das war dieser Amazon Klon von Amazon Gaming,
äh nicht der Amazon Klon, was laber ich denn, der Overwatch, der Amazon Klon von Amazon
Gaming, der Overwatch, das war kein Overwatch Klon, das war so ein komischer Third Person
Overwatch Mix, wo der nicht genau wusste, was es sein soll, was er auch gesagt hat,
was lustigerweise irgendwie 5 Zuschauer auf Twitch hatte, mal für einen Tag irgendwie
10k, wisst ihr was auch übelst gefailt ist, Hyper Scape heißt das glaube ich von Ubisoft,
dieses Ubisoft Battle Royale Ding, passt mal auf und woran man erkennt, dass es übelst
gefailt ist, der meiste Zuschauer Ding hat gerade 61 Zuschauer, exellent, ja, ich musste
mal Chat aufmachen, fällt mir gerade auf, ein Game, der Chat sagt, ein Game, oder besser
gesagt der Elsa sagt, ein Game zu cancel ist so lost, wie kann man sowas nicht vorher
analysieren, ach ich denke die haben vorher schon analysiert, aber die haben wahrscheinlich
einfach Low Brain analysiert, oder aber, bei Amazon bin ich mir da nie so sicher, die machen
ein paar verplante Aktionen, Google aber auch, Google ist da eigentlich Meister der irgendwie
merkwürdigen Aktionen, die haben wahrscheinlich einfach 20 Entwickler gehabt, die gerade nichts
zu tun hatten, haben gesagt, ey Leute wir stecken euch jetzt zusammen in ein Team, macht
mal ein Game, dann kam dann Crucible bei raus, allerdings muss man halt auch sagen, andere
kriegen das halt auch nicht geschissen, guckt euch Dings an hier, EA Anthem, wie siehts
das eigentlich aus, wie siehts eigentlich mit Anthem 2.0 aus, okay, gar nicht, gar nicht,
okay gar nicht, Alter was ist das hier gerade für Biblesam Musik, ah fuck, ach ich seh
das, ah viel besser, ja also mit Anthem 2.0 wird wohl nix, aber das ist ja auch so ein
Ding, was sie richtig verschissen haben, allerdings bei Anthem haben sie dann glaube ich irgendwann
den Fehler gemacht, dass sie gesagt haben, das ist schon zu groß, dass es zu groß zum
failen quasi, denen ist sicherlich auch aufgefallen, dass das Game scheiße ist, also wer nicht
wäre ja noch unfähiger, aber dann haben sie sich gedacht, ey das müssen wir jetzt irgendwie
raus prügeln und irgendwie gucken, dass wir das noch unter die Leute kriegen und vielleicht
dann noch rebuggen, ich mein man darf nicht vergessen, die versuchen das ja sogar so bei
so Fail Games wie Fallout 76, das ist jetzt auch raus und wird permanent irgendwie überarbeitet
und ist wahrscheinlich immer noch scheiße, ein Game, was übrigens super die Kurve gekriegt
hat, nach dem initialen Fail ist, wie hieß dieses Ding, nicht Star Citizen, das andere
Weltraum Ding, No Man's Sky, genau No Man's Sky, ich vergess, No Man's Sky, das hat tatsächlich
die Kurve gekriegt, ich spiel's nicht, aber die müssen es wohl richtig gut hingekriegt
haben nach Release noch, ja Rainbow Six auch, ich hab mich mal übelst über Rainbow Six
am Anfang lustig gemacht, mittlerweile Rainbow Six ist irgendwie im fünften Jahr oder sowas
ne, hast du mit LXD Ahnung, Joast geht, geht so, also No Man's Sky ist mittlerweile wohl
echt ganz gut und es hat wohl sogar Multiplayer, der funktioniert, was ja am Anfang auch gesagt
wurde, das Game hätte Multiplayer und dann haben es zufällig Leute geschafft, doch
auf dem gleichen Planeten zu landen und haben sie nicht gesehen, was halt auch übelst
der Fail war, ja und da haben sie sich verschwissen, was sagt eigentlich, was sagt eigentlich
gerade Fallout 76 auf Twitch, gucken das Leute, ok, ok, ok, das gucken noch weniger als Hyperscape,
das sagt alles über das Game, weniger als Hyperscape und Hyperscape gucken ja schon
so viele Leute, kennst du das Video von Internethistory zu No Man's Sky, ich glaube schon, dass
wir das mal geguckt haben, ja, fällt mir nur noch zu, ich weiß nicht, warum empfiehlt
mir das YouTube wieder, das hatten wir doch eben schon mal und es ist nicht die gleiche
Seite, ich hab es noch ein paar Mal refreshed, perfect, es ist so dumm, es ist so neblig,
man hat sich gedacht, ey, das müssen wir jetzt empfehlen, gucken ob es wieder in den Empfehlungen
ist, nice, ne, ok, das jetzt hab ich geguckt, jetzt hat YouTube sich überlegt, jetzt ist
anderes Zeug angesagt, ok, das hier ist anscheinend die Meme-Compilation-Ecke, oh Leute, ich
bin auch echt halb am Pennen, wir gucken jetzt eine Runde Battlefield, komm mal her,
mit was fangen wir jetzt mal an, ich guck mir immer Server-Bills und Rack-Bills und so
von anderen Leuten an, da kann ich mich immer ein bisschen drüber auslassen, was macht
der hier, jaja, ah, yes, tolle Dell-Kiste, kann doch eine neue Dell-Kiste sein, da kennt
man nicht so genau, die Dinger sind alle gleich aus innen drin, ja, das ist wahrscheinlich
schon neueres, bisschen neueres, nicht ganz so altes, oh, gut, langweilig, so, also, was
gucken wir uns an, ne, das gucken wir uns jetzt zu harte Kost, gucken wir uns jetzt
nicht an, unpickable log from Germany, ok, wenn das Video 186 geht, wird das nicht ganz
so unpickable sein, würde ich sagen, der macht wahrscheinlich, der rüttelt zwei Mal
dran, easy, ja, also, nachdem du ja Apple-User bist, dürfte dich das nicht stören, wenn
es ein bisschen teurer ist, aber qualitativ gut ist und wenn du halt nix anderes willst
als Home-Kit, dann nimm die hier, dann nimm die hier, ja, warte mal, äh, Alt-Bulbs,
du musst ein bisschen gucken, warte mal, wir müssen mal zum EU-Shop, äh, wo kann man,
weil die Dinger gibt's in EU und NA, aber die Produktbezeichnung haben sie irgendwie
anders gemacht, warum auch immer, um die Leute zu verwirren, ja, also die sind nicht schlecht,
also ich hab selbst die da, allerdings musst du mal gucken, der offizielle Preis ist, ist
schon ein bisschen keck, keck, quadruple-U, die kriegst du woanders auch günstiger, also
ich hab da von welchen im Einsatz, ich hab die einmal unten für, ähm, der Unterschied
zwischen der A60 und der A60 Plus ist, die kann noch Infrarot dazu, was ganz praktisch
ist, wenn du Kameras hast mit Nachtsicht-Funktion und die eingebaute Infrarot-LED der Kamera
sagt da ist, das Ding hab ich unten im Flur, der Flur ist hell wie bei Tag, äh, infrarot
mäßig nachts, dann, äh, die hab ich auch am Start und die normale Dim-Barre, die hab
ich auch am Start, genau, aber wie gesagt, die gibt's normalerweise ein bisschen billiger,
wenn wir mal gucken bei Amazon gerade, es ist übrigens egal, ähm, wenn du die in Europa
verkaufst, ob die, äh, die englischen Bezeichnungen, die deutschen Bezeichnungen haben, das Produkt
ist das gleiche, ja, ja, guck mal, äh, also von wegen 65 Euro, hier kostet es 55 Euro
und du kriegst sie teilweise noch ein bisschen günstiger, aber die kann ich empfehlen, ja,
also die haben out of the box-Integration, HomeKit und, äh, Alexa glaub ich, also du
kannst die einfach nur mit dem iPhone einrichten ohne was anderes, aber du kannst sie auch
in fast alle anderen Smart Home Lösungen einbilden, also ich mach's hier drüber, mach
das hier drüber und die haben auch ne LiveX-Integration, da musst du halt die IP von der Lampe dann
angeben und dann kannst du die auch da drüber steuern, funktioniert wunderbar, ja, aber
die sind echt gut, meiner Meinung nach so die besten aber halt auch mit die teuersten
solcher Smart RGB-Dinger, die es gibt und man muss sich, eine Sache, die ich schon gemerkt
hab, ja, du musst bei Amazon holen, nicht hier bei offizieller Shop, das ist doch, äh,
ähm, genau, eine Sache, die ich gemerkt hab mittlerweile, ach, Moment hier, eins bis
drei Monate, what the fuck, das ist übrigens die gleiche, warum ist, ich hab die vor ein
paar Wochen noch eine gekauft, anscheinend ist Weihnachten, äh, die haben Cloudgeschiss,
aber du musst nicht verwenden mit der Integration von Home Assistant, also was ich gemacht hab
ist, die wollen, dass du die offizielle App von denen verwendest und ihr kennt mich ja,
ich hab was gegen offizielle Apps, die man verwenden muss und sonst nichts anderes, was
man machen kann ist, man installiert sich die App und, ähm, dann geht man in den Pairing-Modus
von der Lampe und stellt in der App ein, dass man die Lampe pairen will mit einem Wlan,
das nicht ins Internet kommt und dann schlägt das Fehl beim Adden in denen ihre Cloud, du
brauchst die App nicht, aber die Lampe ist in deinem Wlan und dann kannst du es per
Home Assistant Integration steuern, man muss nur den Wlan in Internet Access verbieten,
ansonsten adden sie es dann in ihre komische Cloud-Lösung, was aber auch nicht schlimm
ist, du kannst es nach wie vor lokal steuern, also du kannst lokal steuern, entweder, es
geht sogar lokal über die App ohne Internet, wenn man das will, die meisten Leute haben
damit ja gar kein Problem, aber ihr wisst ja, ich leg ja Wert drauf, dass meine Sache
komplett ohne Clouds Zeug funktioniert, ok, warum jetzt natürlich der Versand so lange
dauert, ist eine Frage, wahrscheinlich weil Weihnachten ist, aber eine Sache, die mir
bei RGB-Lampen aufgefallen ist schon, ich bin ja da erst so 1-2 Monate mit am rumbasteln,
man sollte sich ernsthaft überlegen, braucht man wirklich RGB oder reicht nicht sowas
hier, also die ganzen Sachen kommen ja in 3 verschiedenen Ausprägungen, das einfachste
ist eine Lampe, die nur dimmbar ist, das ist weiß und du kannst sie aber in der Helligkeit
dimmen, so das ist die einfachste Variante, ok die aller einfachste Variante, ok fahr
mal an, es gibt eine stinknormale Lampe, mit der du nichts machen kannst, schalte an und
aus, na gut, dann hast du die nächste Lampe, die hat vielleicht Wifi, die kannst du über
Wifi ein und ausschalten, so aber wo es bei Lifer gestartet ist, die Einstiegslampe ist
einfach weiß, aber die kannst du dimmen, so das nächste ist, die Lampe, die kannst du
ein ausschalten, WLAN-mäßig dimmen und du kannst die Farbtemperatur einstellen, was
unter der Haube so viel heißt wie, die hier hat quasi ein Set an LEDs, nämlich einfach
nur weiße LEDs dimmbar, die hier hat rot und weiße LEDs, weil sonst kannst du ja nicht
die Farbtemperatur einstellen und ist dimmbar und dann hast du RGB, die ist halt mit 4 LEDs,
also RGB und weiß, so dementsprechend ist die natürlich auch teurer, aber eine Sache,
die mir aufgefallen ist bei RGB Lampen, in den meisten Räumen oder an den meisten Stellen
braucht man gar kein RGB, ich hab zum Beispiel am Anfang im Wohnzimmer drüben eine RGB
hier reingebaut, bis mir dann irgendwann aufgefallen ist, das einzige was ich mache ist An-Aus und
Helligkeit und daraufhin hab ich dann so ein billigeres Ding hier reingebaut, also wenn
man eine Lampe hat, die dimmbar ist und die Farbtemperatur anpassen kann, 90% der Anwendungsgebiete
reicht das komplett, weil mal ganz im Ernst, wo will man beispielsweise grünes, blaues
Licht haben oder violettes, lila, rotes, sonst wie, also das kommt recht selten vor, dass
man wirklich die RGB Komponente von so einer Lampe braucht, das meiste was man will ist
anpassbare Farbtemperatur von der Lampe und dimmbar, Helligkeit und anpassbare Farbtemperatur,
dazu brauchst du nur eine weiße LED und eine rote LED und deswegen sind die Lampen auch
billiger.
Ja also wie gesagt die sind ganz nice, exzellent, was ist das, der gesammelte Corona, oh da
reg ich mich bestimmt wieder auf, das will ich mir hier angucken jetzt, Raspberry Pi
Nass, ihr wisst ich bin der Meinung Raspberry Pi und Nass in Kombination Sacken, allerdings
der verwendet so das Compute Modul wie es aussieht und das Compute Modul hat auch einen
Pizzi Express Stecker und über Pizzi Express kann man natürlich dann irgendeine Raid Karte
oder so dran machen, dann geht der Raspberry Pi eventuell als Nass auch klar, allerdings
ohne Krypto Extensions eher auch nicht.
Das Schloss Video, ok wir gucken uns das Schloss Video am Anfang mal an, gucken wir uns das
Schloss Video an, easy, oh, Mist, hä, Video will Pause, warum, Pause Champ, das Video
soll ich Pause Champen, ok also wenn das Video 3.36 geht, der rüttelt einmal am Schloss
Video und dann ist es auf, er kennt, er kann es nicht picken was mit ihm los, ist es
ein Debate, er hat ja was mit Fallout 76 zu tun, ach so, das ist quasi den anderen Schloss
Video, ein Schloss, also nein, ein Fake Schloss was aussieht wie ein Schloss, ok das ist eigentlich
Big Brain, das sind wie die Plastikkameras die man hinstellen kann die gar keine Kameras
sind, Einbrecher Troll, boah 40 Dollar für, naja, Fake Log, Fake Log, Fake Log, Fake
Log, ok, ok, das war jetzt nicht womit ich gerechnet habe das Video, ich hätte eigentlich
gedacht, das ist ein echtes Schloss, der schüttelt das einmal fest und es geht auf, so nach
dem Motto, aber es ist wirklich unpickable, weil es ist gar kein Schloss, exellent, gut,
gut das jetzt wissen wir Bescheid, so, haben wir sonst noch, Speedrun Zeug, Technik Ideen
für Weihnachten, what the, Technik Ideen für Weihnachten, wurde mir heute Morgen empfohlen,
ich hab keine Ahnung warum, warum wir einfach ne Call of Duty 4 Mission Speedrun empfohlen
wird, kein Plastenschimmer, Youtube, Youtube Algorithmus, bester, kann wer einen Firefox
Addon empfehlen, oh Firefox Addon kenn ich, hab ich nicht geguckt, aber sag mal so wenn
es für Chrome sowas gibt sollte es für Firefox eigentlich auch sowas hier geben, guck doch
mal aus, Volume, Master, Firefox, oh der Soundfixer und 600% Volume, alles klar, ok, ok, ok,
das hab ich sogar schon mal verwendet den Soundfixer, jetzt wo ich den Screenshot sehe,
der hat funktioniert, oh ne, ne, nein, nein das hab ich verwendet, das hab ich verwendet,
sah jetzt nur so ähnlich, das hab ich schon mal verwendet und das funktioniert, 600%
Soundvolume, exellent, die Beschreibung sieht halt aus wie ein China Shop, aber es ist kein
China Shop, da muss ich aber im Klaren sein, ne, also wenn das Addon mal in falsche Hände
gerät ist vorbei und das ist gar nicht so unwahrscheinlich, dass das Addon in falsche
Hände gerät, ich hatte mal nen Addon installiert, ich mach mal kurz die VM auf, ah ja geh fort,
es nannte sich Kappa Everywhere und dann kam, dann kam, dann nen Monat später oder so nachdem
ich das installiert hab ne Meldung so nach dem Motto Addon wurde entfernt und der Typ
der das Addon gemacht hat, also das Addon hat einfach auf allen Webseiten Twitch Emotes
eingeblendet, war eigentlich ganz nice, so und der Typ hat das Addon verkauft und dann
haben irgendwelche Chinesen das Addon umgebaut zu, weiß ich nicht, ob Servieren eingebaut
haben oder Keylogger eingebaut oder irgendwas gemacht, zumindest der hat das Addon verkauft
und die Chinesen andere irgendwelche Dinge gemacht und dann hat es Google aus dem Store
entfernt.
Also man muss schon aufpassen bisschen bei Browser Addons, gerade bei Browser Addons
die wirklich alles lesen können, das ist gar nicht so ohne und so nen Addon Hersteller
ist vielleicht wirklich mal geneigt, wenn er ein gutes Angebot bekommt sein Addon zu
verkaufen inklusive Source Code, GitHub, Zugriff und alles mögliche, tja, naja ok also was
haben wir denn sonst noch hier, wow Battlefield 3, was ist jetzt hier, warum lädt das denn
jetzt auf einmal, wollen die mich veräppeln, ich hab das doch schon alles schonmal aufgemacht,
dass es nicht lädt, ich will nicht, dass es lädt, wenn es lädt dann stürzt es ab oder
wie ging das, äh wenn es lädt dann, war das nicht, wenn es lädt dann stürzt es ab,
es ging doch in der Richtung irgendwie, ich will nicht, dass es lädt, dann muss man wieder
so lange warten, ja, genau der da, der Typ, der Typ hat mittlerweile nen eigenen YouTube
Channel und sieht aus, äh übelst muskulös, ne und die Leute haben das damals ernst genommen,
so unglaublich fail, der hat heute nen eigenen YouTube Channel irgendwie her, Hercules Beats
oder sowas, ja, ne Typ, das ist das übelste Tier mittlerweile, ja, der Unreal Tournament
Spielen Typ, die haben ja damals sogar, äh glaub ich weiß nicht wo das war, in der ARD
oder so berichtet, richtig dumm, da sieht man mal wie hängen geblieben, die Berichterstattung
damals zu Games war und man sieht auch, wie hängen geblieben die Berichterstattung zu
Games immer noch ist, am besten war immer noch der Beitrag letztens bei Frontal 21,
wo sie irgendwie was erzählt haben, irgendwie Nazis unterwandern die Gaming Community oder
sowas, das war auch so fail, Alter, das war so fail und dann hatten sie zwischendrin so
ne Szene, einfach mal so random, was mit dem Thema überhaupt nichts zu tun hatte, so ne
Szene in GTA nachgestellt, wo Leute irgendwelche Frauen geschlagen haben und dann haben sie
gesagt auch noch, dass Gamer Gewalt gegen Frauen befürworten und sowas, richtig dumm,
richtig dummer Schwachsinn ey, was die sich da wieder aus den Fingern gesaugt haben,
mit dem Unterschied ist, bei RTL kann ichs einfach ignorieren, bei ARD bezahle ichs
quasi mit, dass sowas erstellt wird, so, also komm wir gucken ne Runde Battlefield, wir
gucken jetzt ne Runde Battlefield, weil, weil Battlefield, oh, exellent, oh ne Runde Battlefield,
nice, hier, ne ne, das kommt man uns jetzt nicht, beste Ecke, Moment, Moment, das kennen
wir schon, das haben wir schon geguckt, das haben wir letztens abends mal geguckt oder,
das kennen wir schon, das, das nix neues, das kennen wir schon, 2. Dezember, das haben
wir schon geguckt, das haben wir schon geguckt, ok, ok, haben wir noch was anderes, dann,
Leute, dann, dann guck ich mir jetzt den Call of Duty 4 Speedrun an, ich weiß nicht genau,
warum ihr das empfohlen wollt, aber das muss ich mir jetzt angucken, exellent, ah, Schneiber
Mission, Schneiber Mission in 9 Minuten, eigentlich ist die Mission gedacht, ich kann mich doch
dran erinnern, dass man, also, der Anfang ist ja das wo man so durchs Gras stellt und
rum snipern muss und so, aber die zweite Hälfte der Mission ist ja die Geschichte wo man flüchten
muss vor den Gegnern und das ist eigentlich auch so in Etappen gemacht, aber ich wette
mit euch, ihr rennt einfach durch, wenn du so oft streamt geht dir der Content aus, so
einfach geht das, jeder der die Mission mag, normalerweise, ist ja geil, normalerweise dauert
das eine halbe Stunde, ne, der Dude der hier aussteigt aus dem Auto, der rennt hier normalerweise
hin und her und man kann den die ganze Zeit nicht, nicht, nicht, nicht snipen und man
muss einfach nur wissen wo man hin snipen muss, easy, ja easy erstmal, die typische
Call of Duty Sache einfach mal kurz den Heli weg snipen, das, wisst ihr, wisst ihr warum
alle nachfolgenden Call of Duty Kampagnen immer langweiliger wurden, weil die in Call
of Duty 4 mehr oder weniger sich da neu erfunden haben und alle Call of Duty Kampagnen danach
haben das gleiche gemacht, nur mit mehr Explosionen, also vom Gameplay her, vom Ablauf her, die
Story von Black Ops 1 fand ich auch übelst nice, ich wollte übrigens die Story vom neuen
Black Ops unbedingt spielen, habe ich noch nicht gemacht, da musste, damals hat man sich
noch erschreckt, so hohe Fach ist explodiert, heute sagt man, heute sagt man, ja klar ich
wusste das explodiert, guck mal der NPC kommt überhaupt nicht hinterher, na erstmal alles
weg C4 in easy, ok der weiß schon komplett wo die Gegner spawnen und Call of Duty 4 hatte
ja noch diesen Tick, dass du über gewisse Punkte rüber laufen musstest, dass Gegner
spawnen oder Gegner aufhören zu spawnen, das war noch die olle Call of Duty 2 Taktik, wie
sie rumstelsen, das ist übrigens immer noch, weil der so rum bunnyhoppt, das ist ja irgendeine
modifizierte Quake Engine, wahrscheinlich kannst du deswegen da noch ein bisschen bunnyhoppen,
guck es euch an, ok man kann einfach durchrennen, niemand hat das damals so gespielt aber tja
es geht anscheinend, ok man muss halt sagen Call of Duty Kampagnen Missionen sind halt
wenn man weiß wo was gescriptet ist ziemlich lame, ich mein wenn du weißt, dass da gleich
die Tür aufgeht und hinter der Tür 5 Gegner spawnen, dann machst du einfach den da, ok
easy, jetzt kommt der Heli, jeder der die Mission zum ersten mal gespielt hat, hat
halt übelst Panik gekriegt bei diesen Sachen, du bist dann auch weg gerannt vor den Helis
und hast dann irgendwie geguckt, dass du vielleicht irgendwo ein RPG findest oder so, an sich
ist es total einfach wie man hier sieht, genau jetzt kommt die Dinger wo hier der Macmillan
eingequetscht wird unter dem Heli, was halt überhaupt nicht spektakulier aussieht, normalerweise
normalerweise steht man in der Mission ja hier vorne und rennt vor dem Heli weg, wenn
man das normal casual spielt, diese englische Akzent Insta alle haben, I cover you, I cover
you machen sie, ich frag mich ob das alles irgendwelche Leute aus England sind oder ob
die einfach nur fake accent machen, sind das Panik, sowas in der Richtung würde ich schon
sagen ja, weil man sieht es ja auch, man muss permanent die Maus bewegen, was ja seit
den Doom Zeiten und alles was irgendwie auf Doom oder nachfolgenden Quake Sachen basiert,
man muss ja immer die Maus bewegen von links nach rechts und dann springen und nachdem
Call of Duty 4 unter der Haube Quake 3 Engine ist mit heftigen Modifizierungen, wird das
das da auch so sein, nur dass halt das Movement an sich viel langsamer ist, aber es funktioniert,
es funktioniert anscheinend immer noch, normalerweise soll man sich jetzt hier eigentlich so in unterschiedlichen
Etappen durchkämpfen, also massive Boden Textur, man soll den Typ absetzen und Gegner
killen, weiter, Typ absetzen, Gegner killen, aber man kann auch einfach durchrennen, normalerweise
ist das nicht so gedacht, oh Hunde, what the fuck, die Hunde lecken auch critical information
oder, die Hunde sollen dich normalerweise eigentlich bashen, ja die Hunde lecken critical
information, ich glaube man kann nicht angesprungen werden wenn man den Typ trägt und jetzt sind
die Hunde einfach weg, easy, ey wer kennt's aus Warzone, das Ding haben die 1 zu 1 in
Warzone hier so drinnen, das ist das Warzone Schwimmbad, 1 zu 1, also die haben ja, Warzone
ist ja best of aus allen Call of Duty Teilen, normalerweise sind hier doch massig Gegner,
ey wo sind die hin, war der zu schnell, ah da, gescriptet der Gegner, easy, bam in your
face, next, der sieht man mal, der war viel zu schnell, die Gegner sind hinter ihm gerade
gespawnt im Patrouillenmodus, put me down, down, down, ich kann das nicht, oh jetzt kommt
BigBrain, BigBrain Speedrun Strats hier, was gibt das jetzt wenn's fertig ist, und warum
hat er unendlich Claymores, der weiß halt, Call of Duty Missionen sind halt, guckt jetzt
wo man's hier sieht, das ist halt eindeutig das Warzone Schwimmbad, oder besser gesagt,
das Schwimmbad in Warzone ist eindeutig halt das, weil best of Call of Duty, guck sogar
hier die Rehling oben, oder so ist der da am Start, die Call of Duty Missionen wenn du
weißt wo Trigger sind und spawnen sind halt witzlos, die spawnen alle im Scheiß, ja
quasi, normalerweise ist dann hier gegenüber die Feuerwehrstation, einfach, einfach in
den Spawn halten, so muss das sein, woher, woher, woher weiß der Typ, dass der down ist,
der hat den überhaupt nicht gesehen von dahinten, ich könnte mir vorstellen an dieser, der steht
nicht umsonst genau an dieser Pose, das ist bestimmt weil die Hunde nicht zu ihm kommen
dann, alter was ist das, die Gegner, die NPC Gegner die kriegen überhaupt nichts gebacken,
die spawnen einfach und er schießt den Spawn direkt ab, null das ist ja easy mode, das Schwimmbad
genau das Schwimmbad gibt es ja übrigens auch in echt ne, 50.000 Menschen lebten hier und
jetzt ist es ein Ghosthorn, weiter kann ich nicht mehr, da spawnet jetzt gleich was anscheinend
oder auch nicht, was machen die Hunde da, ah wisst ihr was sein kann, dass die Hunde
rumspacken weil er so viel FPS hat, Colossus T4 hatte bei manchen Sachen übelste Probleme
wenn du über 140 FPS hattest, da kannst du auch weiter springen und sowas, ach hier
werden Truppen abgeseilt, exzellent Abseiler ist am Start, da wird abgeseilt, funktioniert
nicht so gut wie es aussieht, noch mehr Abseiler, fast Abseiling, noch mehr, oh habt ihr die
Tags just gesehen, die meine ich nicht, hier die, die hier guck mal, die sehen halt richtig
scheiße aus, RTX off, ok jetzt hat die restlichen Abseiler mit C4 gekillt, was genau machen
die NPCs da eigentlich, da ist doch überhaupt nichts, das sind mit Sicherheit die niedrigsten
Einstellungen, dass er 240 FPS und 250 FPS konstant hat, die NPCs sind ja fast so gut
wie die Battlefield Spieler aus den Top Play Videos, ja es ist halt wirklich komplett easy
mode wenn du weißt wo die Gegner herkommen, aber jede Call of Duty Mission ist easy mode
wenn du weißt wo irgendetwas geträgert wird, einfach hinschinken gerade ausschießen,
17 Monate Dankeschön für die Subscriptions, exzellent, das hat ewig gedauert bis hier
der Heli arrived, jetzt geht er schon mal mit dem NPC dorthin wo der Heli landet, was machen
die Claymores da eigentlich, was ist der Sinn von den Claymores, keiner, die Claymores
triggern mit Sicherheit irgendwelche Gegnerlaufwege oder so, easy as fuck, wie sie reinstälzen,
ich glaube auch, dass die Claymores irgendwelche Laufwege oder Spawn Punkte oder irgendetwas
von NPCs beeinflussen, garantiert, der hat die Claymores nicht ohne Spaß da in die Ecke
geklatscht, oder vielleicht spawnen dort nichts wenn die da stehen, irgendwas, könnt ihr
euch noch an MW3 erinnern, wo du mit Claymores auf dieser Satellitenschüssel Map, wo du
die Spawns einschränken konntest, mit den Claymores, dass die Gegner nur an eine oder
zwei Positionen gespawned sind, und dann hast du dich headclitched hinter so ein Betonpfeiler
und hast mit der LMG einen Spawn geschossen, pause los, ah nice, ich glaube jeder der das
zum ersten mal spielt, braucht irgendwie eine halbe Stunde plus oder so für die Mission,
excellent, exquisite speedrun, so was gucken wir uns jetzt als nächstes an, zeig mal ja,
ich hab gesagt ich guck's mir nicht an, weil ich mich aufrege, jetzt hab ich ne Runde gameplay
geguckt, jetzt können wir uns die drei Minuten mal geben, so, wahrscheinlich ist das wieder
irgendwas wo ich sagen muss, die spinnen wieder alle, das ist Familie Heuer aus Lüneburg,
ja exellent, das wollte ich schon, skype, Leute was ist das hier, skype, bezahlen wir
euch zu wenig Rundfunkgebühren oder was, warum müsst ihr skype verwenden, wir brauchen,
also ok, ok, also wenn meine Rundfunkgebühren dafür verwendet werden, dass die kein skype
mehr verwenden, sondern irgendwas ordentlich ist, dann bezahle ich die sogar, letztens
gab es so ein Interview mit irgendeiner öffentlich rechtlichen, frag mich nicht, irgendeiner
Frau vom öffentlich rechtlichen und da sieht man mal was für Boomers da sitzen, die hat
gesagt, es ist Zeit für ein öffentlich rechtliches Facebook, also erstens, Facebook interessiert
von den jüngeren Leuten absolut niemand und dazu kommt, wer will denn öffentlich, also
ich mein ich will ja schon kein Facebook haben, aber wer will denn noch ein öffentlich rechtliches
Facebook haben, ok, ok, also guck mal mal, das ist Familie XY aus Lüneburg oder von wo
die herkommen, also zeig mal her, aha, also am Samstag kriegen wir einen Anruf in der
Schule, dass in der Parallelklasse von Lale ein Corona-Fall, die Tochter hat kein Bock
auf das Video, guckt es euch mal an, lul, guckt es euch mal an, die hat überhaupt kein
Bock das aufzunehmen, dieses Alter pisst, pisst euch alle, ich will es nicht, ein bestätigter
Corona-Fall ist und dass der gesamte Jahrgang für eine Woche zu Hause bleiben soll, gesagt,
Lale, Lale, per E-Mail, per E-Mail, oh wir sind im Jahr 2020 angekommen, die Schulen schicken
E-Mails, du nennst dein Kind 0W, gute Wahl, gute Wahl, besser als KekWee auf jeden Fall,
ja, weil ja mit Sicherheit, was ja bekannt ist, weil in der Schule die Kinder nur immer
einzig und allein Leute aus der eigenen Klasse anstecken, tja, noch während des laufenden
Dienstagvormittag Unterricht sind dann die Kinder, die in der Schule waren, in Quarantäne
geschickt worden, oh das ist ja wieder so fail, erst sagen, ihr dürft nicht kommen, dann sagen,
ihr müsst wieder kommen und am Tag, wo die Leute wieder in die Schule gehen, dann sagen,
ihr könnt wieder heimgehen, was ist das für eine Logik, das hier Sterbehilfe, das ist
eine gute Frage, warum sind die im Skype, wenn die eh vorbeikommen und die Tochter
filmen, das ist eine sehr gute Frage, ja, es gibt viele so öffentlich-rechtliche Beiträge
oder generell Beiträge im Fernsehen, wo ich mich das so frage, was machen die eigentlich
da, genauso wenn sie irgendwelche Szenen stellen, so nach dem Motto, hier gibt es jetzt eine,
was hab ich letztens für ein Video gesehen, es gibt irgendwie eine Aufräumaktion am Strand
und der Typ hatte keinen Bock, die Aufräumaktion am Strand zu filmen, also hat er den Leuten
nach der Aufräumaktion gesagt, räumt mal bitte für mich auf, dass ich euch filmen kann,
so.
... uns telefonisch mitgeteilt hat, schauen wir zwischendurch mal auf eine etwas andere
Schule, die Hundeschule von Jennifer Yeckel in Vellberg in Nordrhein-Westfalen, das ist
zwar keine Schule im klassischen Sinne, aber...
Das Ordnungsamt hat gesagt, dass meine Hundeschule eine Bildungseinrichtung sei.
Ja, dann ist doch alles Paletti, schließlich sind die Schulen...
Und was?
Warum ist die Hundeschule eine Bildungseinrichtung, Alter?
Klassischen Sinne, aber...
Das Ordnungsamt hat gesagt, dass meine Hundeschule eine Bildungseinrichtung sei.
Ja, dann ist doch alles Paletti...
What?
Warum?
Das ist eine Hundeschule, ist das eine Bildungseinrichtung?
Ich meine, vielleicht, ja, manche Hunde haben sicherlich mehr Hirn als manche Leute.
Schließlich sind die Schulen doch geöffnet.
In NRW ist es so, dass alle Bildungseinrichtungen schließen müssen, außer Schulen, Universitäten,
Volkshochschulen und Musikschulen dürfen auch geöffnet bleiben, alle anderen Schwimmschulen,
Hundeschulen und ähnliche, müssen zu sein.
Was ist mit der Baumschule?
Die Kommunen in NRW entscheiden selbst, wie sie die Corona-Schutzverordnung auslegen.
Das hat uns das Ministerium für Arbeit, Gesundheit und Soziales mitgeteilt.
Das heißt?
Ja, das heißt, jedes Amt entscheidet dann am Ende doch wieder was anderes, sodass wir
permanentes Chaos haben.
Ich darf ausschließlich Welten Spiel anbieten, dabei darf ich aber auf keinen Fall Wissen
vermitteln an die Hunde, halt.
Oh, das ist so fail, wieder.
Meine Kolleginnen in Essen dürfen Einzeltraining im öffentlichen Bereich machen, nicht auf
den Betriebsgelände.
Die Kolleginnen in Ratingen oder in Hagen zum Beispiel dürfen auf dem Betriebsgelände
ganz normal...
Da kann doch niemand durchblicken.
Das ist doch unmöglich.
Da kann doch keiner durchblicken.
Wie willst du da durchsteigen?
Aber wisst ihr, was das Gute ist?
Diejenigen, die das theoretisch kontrollieren müssen, die blicken da auch nicht durch.
Also im Prinzip macht es überhaupt keinen Unterschied.
Wahrscheinlich, weil keiner durchblickt.
Aber muss ich mal ehrlich, ähm, ja Riko, denke ich mir auch, einfach weitermachen,
bis sich einer beschwert, weil die, die sich beschweren müssen, blicken da auch nicht
durch.
Aber mal ganz im Ernst, bei solchen Geschichten, bei solchen absolut wirren Regelwerken,
die dann auch noch in jeder Himmelsrichtung unterschiedlich ausgelegt werden, da muss
sich doch echt keiner wundern, dass man mit sowas die Leute gegen sich aufbringt.
Oder?
Also mal ganz im Ernst, da hängt ja die Existenz von manchen Leuten dran.
Also dass man, dass ich da dann, dass man da die Leute gegen sich aufbringt, da muss
ich ja nur wirklich keiner wundern.
Außerdem, und das ist ja das, was mich bei der ganzen Sache immer auffällt, man hatte
6 Monate Zeit zwischen Welle 1 und Welle 2, sich was auszudenken, anhand der Erfahrung,
die man gemacht hat, oder zumindest ein paar Pläne auszuarbeiten, ein paar Sachen vorzubereiten
und diese Sachen im Vorfeld schon abzustimmen, dass dann alle mittragen, wenn es so weit
ist.
Hat man aber nicht gemacht.
Man hat sich 6 Monate hingesetzt und hat sich gedacht, hoffentlich gibt es keine zweite
Welle, hoffentlich gibt es keine zweite Welle, oh fuck, doch zweite Welle.
Ja, da müssen wir jetzt übers Knie brechen und uns irgendwas ausdenken.
Da ist irgendwie nichts passiert, ne?
Dann keine Erklärung, warum, was, wie und warum nicht, dann gibt es komische Regelungen
in Läden, die eher dazu führen, dass Schlangen sich vor Läden bilden und solche Dinge, das
ist so nicht nachvollziehbar irgendwie, also so von oben herab entschieden, ohne dass man
nachvollziehen könnte, warum was gemacht wird.
Ich habe ja nichts dagegen, dass was gemacht wird, gar nicht, ich sehe es ja auch so, dass
was gemacht werden muss, aber es ist nicht nachvollziehbar, warum, was, wie gemacht wird.
Noch weniger nachvollziehbar, was man jetzt darf heute und morgen und vielleicht übermorgen
wieder darf und dann nicht.
Das ist allein schon, wenn du Tennis spielen gehen willst, es gibt Bundesländer, da ist
es nicht geregelt, es gibt Bundesländer, die haben gesagt, wir klären es noch, wir sind
noch in der Entscheidung, es gibt Bundesländer, da darfst du Tennis spielen, es gibt Bundesländer,
da darfst du Tennis nur draußen spielen, es gibt Bundesländer, da darfst du in der Halle
und draußen spielen, wer soll da durchblicken, ja, da kann ich echt verstehen, dass man mit
sowas die Leute gegen sich aufbringt, zumal, wie gesagt, wahrscheinlich die Existenz,
von der hier mit der Hundeschule dranhängt.
Also man muss, wenn man will, dass sich möglichst viele Leute dranhalten und das muss ja eigentlich
das Ziel sein.
Das Ziel müsste sein, dass man die Sachen so vermittelt, dass sich möglichst viele
dranhalten, weil wenn sich keiner dranhält, ist ja auch irgendwie sinnlos.
Dementsprechend müsste es da doch etwas mehr Input geben, warum man wie was entscheidet
und vor allem, was heute gilt.
Ja, es wäre übrigens eine richtig gute Idee, wenn es eine Corona.info gebe, wo tagesaktuell
drinne steht, wo man seine Postleitzahl eingibt und tagesaktuell drinne steht, was, wie, wo,
welche Regelungen gelten.
Das wäre doch mal was, Corona.info, gibst 1-603-29-Frankfurt und kriegst eine Liste,
mit was du darfst, was du nicht darfst, das wäre doch mal was, da könnte man sich irgendwie
halbwegs danach richten.
Ahja, gut.
Wow, das ist ja ein tolles Durcheinander, zurück zu Familie Heuer.
Schauen wir da.
Hallo, wir sind wieder da.
Wie ging es denn weiter?
Wir kriegten auch eine andere.
Die Sprecherin vom Beitrag triggert mich irgendwie, das ist irgendwie nervig betont
alles.
Anweisung, dass ein Elternteil oder Betreuer mit in Quarantäne muss.
Na schön, aber bei der Frage, wer das sein soll, da hat das Gesundheitsamt Herz gezeigt.
Wir durften uns das frei aussuchen, schnick, schnack, schnuck.
Aber die wohnen doch alle zusammen.
Wie soll denn das funktionieren?
Muss dann der Vater sich einschließen im Zimmer oder was?
Und wer hat verloren?
Quarantäne als Gesellschaftsspiel.
Oh, Payne's Champ, der Inhalt ist ja eigentlich ganz gut, aber der Beitrag ist irgendwie Payne's
Champ gemacht.
Ja, aber da musst du dich echt nicht wundern, wenn die Leute da keinen Bock drauf haben
bei so unnachvollziehbarem Krempel.
Es ist bei uns, beim Rewe, im Rewe einkaufen, da stehen jetzt Schilder, man soll die Maske
auf dem, also man soll quasi schon beim Aussteigen aus dem Auto auf dem Parkplatz eine Maske
aufziehen.
Und was meint ihr, wie viele Leute das gemacht haben?
Ich hab da eine Weile gestanden, bestimmt eine Viertelstunde, hab gewartet, ich hab da
vielleicht eine Viertelstunde fünf Leute mit Maske draußen gesehen auf dem Parkplatz,
weil das sind da Sachen, das kann keiner nachvollziehen.
Warum sollste aus dem Parkplatz, wo die nächsten zehn Meter um dich drumherum keiner ist, warum
sollste Maske anziehen?
Dematogen machen es die Leute halt auch nicht.
Tom FMZ Stufe 1, dankeschön für den Sub, Massive Big Brain Subscription, und sie haben
auch echt nachgelassen, muss man sagen, sehr leise und ordentliches OC-Porter, komm wir
gucken uns doch noch eine Runde den Aua an.
Die haben auch nachgelassen, die hatten die ganze Zeit Desinfektionsmittel und so ein
Typ am Eingangstehen vom Rewe, der einem den Wagen desinfiziert hat, den gibt es aber
nicht mehr.
Der Wagen desinfizierer wurde wegrationalisiert, der war wahrscheinlich zu teuer, jetzt werden
die Wagen einfach nicht mehr desinfiziert und wir hoffen, dass die Leute selbst was
dabei haben.
Vielleicht hat er sich auch angesteckt, vielleicht hat er den Wagen abgeleckt, weiß ja nicht,
vielleicht war er auch zu teuer, vielleicht hat das Arbeitsamt auch den 2,50 Euro die
Stunde Job nicht mehr weiter angeboten.
So, der Aua, was hat er heute, eine RTX 3060 Ti, dann zeig ich mal her, ach stimmt, heute
ist ja Nikolaus, kommt der Nikolaus morgens oder abends bei euch, falls der Nikolaus überhaupt
noch kommt, morgens, also bei mir früher kam der Nikolaus immer abends, aber ich glaube
dann auch am fünften abends, nicht heute abends und bei wem kam Knecht Ruprecht und
hat euch den Bobbes versohlt, aber das kann ja hier bei dem Chat nicht passieren, der
Chat ist ja...
Früher kam, ja bei uns kam der Nikolaus auch immer abends, bzw. der Nikolaus kam eigentlich
gar nicht, meine Mutter hat der Nachbarin immer irgendwie das in die Hand gedrückt
und die hat es dann an die Tür gehängt und geklopft und ist schnell weggerannt.
Das war der Nikolaus bei uns und man, was man, was man ohne Scheiß, was man an diesem ganzen
Weihnachtszeug erkennt ist, also zumindest bei mir, wie sehr Einbildung dazu führen
kann, dass man Dinge sieht und wahrnimmt, die es gar nicht gibt, meine Mutter hat mir früher
auch immer erzählt, wo ich klein war, da kann ich mich heute noch dran erinnern, heute kommt
vielleicht der Weihnachtsmann, aber früher ist auch das Christkind gekommen, ja, so und
die hat das damals immer so gemacht, die hat so eine Zeitschaltuhr ins Wohnzimmer gemacht
an den Weihnachtsbaum und wir haben uns dann vor das Wohnzimmer gesetzt und irgendwann
so im Laufe von einer Viertelstunde oder halben Stunde ging dann das Licht drinne an und die
Musik an, halt mit der Zeitschaltuhr, so und mir hat sie halt erzählt, das Christkind kommt
durchs Fenster und legt die Geschenke hin und macht dann das halt an, so und ich hab
das halt komplett geklaubt und ich bin dann immer, wenn die Musik angegangen ist, ich
hab quasi schon in der Startschussposition, also an der Tür gewartet und sobald die Musik
anging, bin ich reingerannt, weil ich mir gedacht hab, so schnell kann das Christkind
ja nicht weg sein, wie ich da reingehe und es war jedes Mal das Fenster zu, die Musik
an und kein Christkind zu sehen, aber einmal bin ich ans Fenster gerannt und hab's gesehen,
ohne Scheiß, ich war damals der Meinung, ich hab das Christkind bei wegfliegen sehen und
da sieht man mal, was so an Sachen glauben, was das machen kann, was das eigentlich auslösen
kann, wer weiß was ich gesehen hab, irgendeine Spiegelung im Fenster oder so, das ist der
Wahnsinn, deswegen wundert es mich nicht, dass in Spanien und Italien, ich glaub in
Spanien ist es, da gibt's ja irgendwie Statistik drüber, muss man mal überlegen, ich glaub
in Spanien ist das Land, wo den meisten Leuten auf der Welt die Jungfrau Maria erscheint,
warum, weil die da voll dran glauben, weißt du, die Spanier laufen durch die Straße,
es fällt ihnen irgendwas auf den Kopf, sie werden kurz unmächtig, kommen ins Krankenhaus
und was erzählen sie, die Jungfrau ist mir erschienen, ja gut, wenn man voll überzeugt
daran glaubt und man irgendwas auf den Kopf kriegt und sich dein Hirn irgendwas zusammenfantasiert,
dann siehst du halt auch so Dinger, Leute die den ganzen Tag World of Warcraft raiden
und denen fällt was auf den Kopf, die spinnen sich dann wahrscheinlich was über irgendwelche
Raid-Endbosse zusammen oder so, also ich war nur einmal unmächtig in meinem Leben,
das weiß ich noch, zumindest wo ich das mitbekommen habe, dass ich unmächtig war, weil ich in
der Ecke gelegen hab, das war, ich hab, das war auch daheim, also gar nichts wildes, ich
hab irgendwie gefühlt zwei Stunden auf dem Sofa gelegen und hab, wahrscheinlich war das
zur N64 Zeit, hab N64 gespielt oder irgendwas, keine Ahnung, ich hab auf dem Sofa gelegen
und gespielt, so und dann hab ich mir gedacht, ah Mist, du musst mal aufs Klo und da bin
ich nach zwei Stunden liegen aufgesprungen vom Sofa und bin aufs Klo gerannt, weil ich
weiter spielen wollte und wahrscheinlich hab ich nicht genug geatmet dabei oder sonst
was, ich bin auf halber Strecke zum Klo unmächtig geworden und gegen den Spiegel geknallt,
so, das weiß ich noch, ich bin da wieder zu mir gekommen, ich bin da wieder zu mir
gekommen, wo ich so auf halb acht in der, dort wo wir die Schuhe früher immer abgestellt
haben neben der Tür, ich lag dann so über die Schuhe drüber und über die Kisten mit
dem Kopf gegen den Spiegel im Flur und hab gedacht, hä, was ist denn hier los, irgendwas
stimmt nicht und das witzige ist, ich kann mich noch genau dran erinnern, mein Hirn hat
sich versucht, irgendwas zusammen zu reimen, was Sinn ergibt und das letzte, also das
erste woran ich mich wieder erinnern kann, nachdem ich wieder zu mir gekommen bin oder
wo ich zum zu mir kommen war, ist, dass ich gedacht habe, ich liege noch auf dem Sofa
und spiele N64 und dann bin ich weiter zu mir gekommen, hab mir gedacht, nee, irgendwas
stimmt hier nicht, du bist gar nicht auf dem Sofa, ah, du bist bestimmt auf dem Klo,
ich hab gesagt, nee, du bist auch nicht auf dem Klo, so und dann bin ich zu mir gekommen
und hab gesagt, ah nee, du liegst im Flur auf dem Boden, ja, das ist das einzige woran
ich mich erinnern kann, dass ich unmächtig geworden bin, aber ich hab einfach zu lange
gelegen und bin dann zu schnell aufgesprungen und zu schnell aufs Klo gerannt, ne, kommt
ja, wenn du aus dem Liegen aufspringst, dann ist halt einfach das Blut noch nicht schnell
genug im Kopf und du kippst halt um, dir, ah, okay, gucken wir uns mal den Bauer an,
was hat er denn hier?
Hallo zusammen, herzlich willkommen zu einem weiteren Video, wir schauen uns heute gemeinsam
die RCX 3060, Alter, die ist ja fett, warum sind denn Mittelklasse Grafikkarten mittlerweile
schon dreieinhalb Huge Zoll groß, äh, nicht, nee, nicht dreieinhalb, zweieinhalb, hä?
KTI Gaming Pro OC 8G an, die Grafikkarten haben wir ja immer, immer länger, die Grafikkarten
haben wir, naja, immerhin, immerhin heißt die nicht Killer Fertility Headshot Pro Hercules
Extreme iChill Windforce oder so, das ganze zu merken, ja, die 3060 ist da, das heißt,
wir schauen uns heute an, was diese spezielle Karte hier kann, also das Modell, wir bauen
die auseinander, die sollte eigentlich vom Aufbau her sehr, sehr ähnlich zu unser 3090
sein, boah, das ist aber auch ein riesen fettes Teil, äh, gleiches Design, Kühleraufbau sollte
alles ähnlich sein, ich denke mal, die Karte ist quasi einfach nur ein kleiner Bruder von
der 3090, werden wir mal sehen, wenn wir die gleich demontieren, was die Performance betrifft,
hat, wieviel Slots braucht die 3090, zweieinhalb oder dreieinhalb, die 3060, oder, oder, oder
klatt drei, die 3060 von den Leaks, die es bisher gab, ja, so um 2080, oder zwischen
2080 und 2080 TI Performance liegen, da machen wir den ein oder anderen, mindestens drei,
aber natürlich auch, wie sich die Grafikkarte, da sind die, da sind die ganzen 280 Käufer,
sind die 280 Superkäufer, sind übelst am Flame, die sagen, oh, Grafikkarte, die die
Hälfte kostet, ist so schnell wie meine Grafikkarte, oh, vielen Pippenhands, kann ja überhaupt
nicht sein, und ich sag mir, endlich tut sich mal ein bisschen was in der Grafikkarte wieder,
ich find's gut, aber ich, ich hab auch keine 2080 gekauft, ich hab immer noch meine 1080
TI, 1080 TI war ne super Karte, äh, richtig schnell für die Zeit, und auch übermäßig
schnell vom Performance-Zuwachs her zur letzten Generation, dass sich's richtig gelohnt hat,
also ich hab die 2080 einfach ausgelassen.
... und was man da vielleicht noch zusätzlich rausholen kann.
Los geht's.
Dieses Video wird präsentiert von Corsair und den neuen üblichen Häusern der 4000er
Serie.
Das 4000er-Optimal für die Reagierenden sind angebotene und RAM-Optik, die ihr steuern
könnt.
Mehr erfahrt ihr über den Link in der Beschreibung.
Wundert euch, wenn die Corsair-Software nur nicht so kacke wär.
Ich wüble ich nicht, also ich mach für meinen Tests immer die Slotblende ab, aber wir haben
hier Anschluss technisch zweimal Displayport und zweimal HDMI, weißt du, was ich sag?
Ja, das sollte reichen, ne?
Ich hab zum Vergleich mal die RTX 3090 daneben gepackt, die kennt ihr aus meinem bisherigen
Video, da seht ihr in der Mitte diese Serie-Nummer-Szene, die ich damals schon bemängelt habe.
Kannst du dir Sponsor-Blog holen?
Ne, mach ich nicht, ich hol mir keinen Sponsor-Blog, weil ich denke, wenn ihr schon Videos gucken
auf YouTube von anderen Leuten, da können wir wenigstens die Werbung von denen uns mal
kurzzeitig geben.
Das haben wir auf der RTX 3060 Ti auch wieder, generell ist das Design sehr sehr ähnlich,
es ist einfach nur eine kleinere Karte, ein kleinerer Kühler, ist ja klar, weil die Leistungsaufnahme
der RTX 3060 Ti ist bei der RTX 3090.
Grundsätzlich ist das Design aber sehr sehr ähnlich, aber ihr seht, da in der Mitte oben
hängt wieder der Serie-Nummer-Sticker, wo ich mich frage, warum macht man den nicht
auf die Platine?
Das ist wirklich eine gute Frage, weil die Grafikkarte sieht an sich ja eigentlich ganz
schick aus, aber da muss da so ein komischer Sticker drauf und unten QR-Code, wir scannen
heute nicht den QR-Code.
Bei der RTX 3060 haben wir das sogenannte Screen-Cooling, das heißt, wir haben hinten ein Kühler bzw.
die Backplate hat ein Loch, wo dann die Luft durchströmen kann, so wie bei der RTX 3090
das schon der Fall war.
Wir haben allerdings auch die gleichen Stromanschlüsse wieder, also das sind Stromanschlüsse, die
wie so eine Cable-Extension sind, also da seht ihr, hier sind Kabel dahinter und die
Backplate...
Merkt man das als Content-Creator, wenn jemand Sponsor-Blog installiert hat?
Ne, merken tust du das nicht, du merkst vielleicht, wenn es viele haben, dass du unnormal wenig
Einnahmen hast, ja, aber die meisten verdienen ihr Geld eh nicht mit AdSense.
Ein Teil des Luftstroms, das hatten wir hier bei der RTX 3090 schon, das wurde bei der
RTX 3060 auch weiter übernommen.
Bei der RTX 3090 hatte ich damals bemängelt, dass ich die Stecker hier schlecht verwenden
lassen, also dass man die Stromstecker schwer einstecken kann, weil die Pins so ein bisschen
wackelig sind.
Das ist bei der RTX 3060 nicht mehr der Fall, also die sind fest, auch wenn die Konstruktion
für mich identisch aussieht, die Pins hier sind wirklich solide und ich hatte keine Probleme
mit Kabel einstecken, also das war auf jeden Fall gut.
Optisch macht die Karte ansonsten einen sehr wertigen Eindruck, wir haben drei große Lüfter,
Kühlleistung sollte auf jeden Fall ausreichend vorhanden sein, kein großes RGB, wir haben
vorne auf der Vorderseite, wenn ich das gleich umdrehe, haben wir ein Gigabyte-Logo, wo auf
jeden Fall minimal RGB-Beleuchtung da ist, aber ansonsten eher ein schlichtes und funktionales
Design.
Hauptsache irgendwo noch eine RGB-LED reingeklatscht, ob man sie jetzt dahin haben muss oder nicht,
ohne RGB-LED gibt es heute nichts mehr.
Sieht gut aus, es gefällt mir immer sehr sehr gut, ich finde es immer mega schön, wie Gigabyte
diese ganzen einzelnen Ausschnitte überall hat, hier wird wirklich jeder Millimeter genutzt,
um die maximale Oberfläche für den Kühler zu generieren, das ist wirklich immer sehr
sehr schön zu sehen, wir haben die Direct Heatpipes Touch, das heißt die GPU liegt hier direkt
auf den Heatpipes auf, wir haben da fünf Stück, wenn ich mich nicht verzeihlt habe, hier außen
an dem Rahmen, da liegen dann die Speicher auf und hier vorne werden die Power Stages
von der GPU direkt gekühlt.
Wir werfen jetzt mal kurz einen Blick auf die Platine und auf den Aufbau der Platine
an sich, also rechts eben Spannungszufuhr, das kennen wir, die Anschlüsse hier sind
keine Standard PC-Express Anschlüsse, bedeutet im Umkehrschluss auch, dass diese Karte sich
Null dafür eignet, wassergekühlt zu werden, weil ihr immer diese Kabelerweiterungen hier
rechts brauchen würdet, falls ihr da einen Wasserkühler drauf habt.
Warum genau macht man da Custom Anschlüsse dran?
Warum denkt sich ein Hersteller, es ist eine gute Idee da für Custom Anschlüsse zu machen?
Aufmontiert, deswegen, wenn ihr euch für dieses Modell entscheidet, dann entscheidet
euch direkt entweder Wasserkühlung ja, nein, mit Wasserkühlung ja, wäre das auf jeden
Fall ein Ausschlusskriterium für die Karte.
Okay, das ist eine Begründung, die lasse ich akzeptieren.
Das bedeutet, der untere ist für diesen Stromanschluss, der obere für diesen Stromanschluss,
was solltet ihr Standmods machen wollen, wären diese zwei die wichtigen.
Dann haben wir hier rechts die Rahmspannungsversorgung, da haben wir zwei Phasen, da sehen wir anhand
dieser zwei Spuren und dieser zwei Kondensatoren.
Wir haben hier auf der rechten Seite so ein bisschen traditionelles Design mit einem Highside
und einem Lowside MOSFET.
Ah ja, alles klar, traditionelles Design, da kenne ich auch sofort.
Zum Einsatz, wo eben auch die Leistungsaufnahme nicht so extrem hoch ist und da wir hier
mit nur 8GB GDDR6 verbaut haben, ist es auch nicht notwendig, da reicht auf jeden Fall
diese Spannungsversorgung hier aus.
Werden wir später auch sehen, dass Overclocking technisch trotz der, sage ich mal, günstigen
Spannungsversorgung einiges drin ist bei dieser Karte.
Hier links ist die komplette GDDR6.
Zeitgenerationen der Familie.
U-Spannungsversorgung, da haben wir insgesamt sieben Phasen.
Ah, das ist jetzt aber keine klassische Aufbau, ja?
Dreien für die GPU zuständig, dann haben wir hier oben nochmal eine einzelne Phase
und hier nochmal eine und hier nochmal eine, das sind dann so zusatzspannungen wie 1,8V,
3,3V oder so was.
Katze im Hintergrund, ja.
Je nachdem, was für ein Controller was braucht und hier oben in der Mitte haben wir dann
nochmal einen BIOS-Switch, wo wir zwischen Silent und OC BIOS-Switch...
Oh, da passi droppt hier wieder die Knowledge-Bombs, ich seh's.
...können also die linke Stellung, die jetzt gerade zu sehen ist, das ist die OC-Einstellung,
die Standard-Einstellung und nach rechts geschaltet wäre dann das Silent BIOS.
Und was ich persönlich eher...
Die Katze ist aus dem Fenster gesprungen?
Wat?
Die sitzt doch da.
Gerade finde ich, dass die Backplate eigentlich nur...
Wat?
Nee, oder?
Ist hier was passiert?
Also Katzen halten eigentlich relativ viel aus, wenn's um Runterspringen geht, so.
Woher hast du das?
Hat er das auf Twitter geschrieben?
Also die Katzen sind, ach so, in einem Video, ja.
Denn nachdem das hier das Video von vor 5 Tagen ist...
Ach echt?
Ah, Mist.
Döde Katze, warum macht die sowas denn?
Warum springt die einfach aus dem Fenster?
Arme Katze.
Weil es einen mechanischen Zweck hat, also entweder gibt's der Karte Stabilität, dass
man die nicht so verbiegen kann, oder eben für die Optik, aber es ist einfach ungenutzte
Kühlung, weil man hätte hier einfach ein, zwei Wärmeleitpads anbringen können, das
könnt ihr natürlich auch nachträglich problemlos machen, und dann entweder auf die Rückseite
der GPU, auf der Rückseite der Speicher, Rückseite von der Spannungsversorgung und so hätte man
definitiv wahrscheinlich noch ein, zwei, drei Grad irgendwo rausholen können.
Selbst wenn es nur ein Grad ist, ist es einfach ungenutztes, es ist einfach ungenutztes Kühlpotenzial,
deswegen schade, dass hier nichts genutzt wurde.
Leuchtet ein.
Was er sagt.
Man kann es persönlich nachrüsten, wenn man sich diese Karte holt.
Nach einer Stunde im Time Spy Extreme Loop Test sehen wir jetzt auch, wo standardmäßig
ungefähr die Temperaturen und auch die Lüftergeschwindigkeit liegt, also Temperatur sieht man ist, dass...
Also ich hab grad nebenbei auf Instagram geguckt, seiner Katze geht's gut, und das
war schon im August, wo die aus dem Fenster gesprungen ist, so wie es aussieht.
Also alles, alles gut gegangen.
Die hat sich ein bisschen was am Bein getan, so wie es aussieht.
Alles gut.
Ziel der Lüftersteuerung 60 Grad, das kann man sehr gut erkennen, die Lüftergeschwindigkeit
bei 1800 Umdrehungen im offenen Aufbau und ihr könnt's im Hintergrund hören oder auch
nicht.
Also die Karte ist wirklich sehr leise, sehr sehr angenehm muss man sagen.
Ja gut, Lautstärkeaufnahmen über Mikrofon ohne irgendwelche Vergleichsdinger sind immer
schwierig.
Also das kann laut oder leise sein, das kann man jetzt nicht darüber schlecht erkennen.
Der Takt bei 1935 MHz, die ganze Zeit stabil.
So ist die Karte jetzt unter Last.
Also Volllast wirklich im Benchmark.
Warum hat das Mainboard hier neben so ein 4-Pin Molex-Ding, wofür ist das?
Ich hatte noch nie ein Mainboard mit so einem Anschluss, das ist ein spezielles Overclocker
Poggers-Mainboard.
Ich versuche, ob ihr das hören könnt oder eben auch nicht, also mir persönlich macht
die Karte auf jeden Fall einen sehr sehr guten Eindruck, der Kühler ist für die Karte definitiv
ausreichend dimensioniert, sodass selbst unter Volllast die Lüfter jetzt nicht so krass
hochdrehen müssen, dass es irgendwie unangenehm wird, also kann man sich als luftgekühlte
Karte definitiv in System bauen.
Wie gesagt, ihr wisst ja, ich bin generell kein Wasserkühlungsfan, also bei mir, wie
gesagt, ich würde auch eine Karte auswählen danach, wie sich das eignet für Luftkühlung.
Übrigens, die gleichen Lüfter habe ich auch drauf, die Dinger sind echt gut, auch wenn
auch ein bisschen teuer, also die fetten Noctua-Dinger werde ich mir auch in mein nächsten Rechner
wieder rein machen und ich bin einfach kein Wasserkühlungsfan, da war ich noch nie, da
werde ich mit jetzt wahrscheinlich auch erstmal nicht anfangen, es sei denn es gibt immer
irgendwie ein Setup oder Kombi, wo ich sage, hey, das ist so viel geiler mit Wasserkühlung,
dann mache ich das vielleicht, keine Probleme haben, was die Lautstärke betrifft.
Nachdem wir jetzt wissen, wie die Temperaturen sind und auch die Lüftegeschwindigkeit und
Last, würde ich jetzt sagen, wir legen mal kurz den Bios-Switch hier um und schauen mal,
was sich dann ändert.
Hm, also die Funktion zum Silent-Bios, die ist mir jetzt nicht so ganz klar, lustigerweise
haben wir jetzt damit einen höheren Takt als vorher, wir haben statt 1935, 1950 Mhz eigentlich
immer durchgehend bei der GPU, es lief jetzt wieder eine halbe Stunde, immer noch um die
60 Grad und immer noch um die 1800, keine Unterschiede, auf dem Lüfter, irgendwie hat
sich dadurch nichts getan, interessant.
Also Overclocking bei der Cardi kann sich auch absolut sehen lassen, nach einer halben
Stunde, 2055 Mhz stabil, Overclocking einfach nur plus 130 Mhz beim GPU Boost, Fanspeed
ist immer noch stock, man sieht aber natürlich, es ist ein bisschen höher als vorher, 50
Umdrehungen, also gar nicht so viel, GPU ist minimal wärmer, das ist aber absolut okay,
liegt auch daran, weil ich hier Power Target hochgezogen habe, oh das könnt ihr gar nicht
sehen, glaub ich, ne?
So, Power Target 112%, Bildschirm abfilmen in 2020, GPU Target, Temperatur Target auf
90 Grad Celsius, auch wenn sie das natürlich bei beiden nicht erreicht, aber ja, das sieht
eigentlich ganz gut aus.
Wir starten unsere Benchmarks mit dem 3D Mark Times bei Xtreme, welchen 4K Auflösung aus?
Lass mal gucken im Vergleich, also, das Ding ist ungefähr, ach ne, das ist nachdem, was
übertaktet hat, okay.
Okay, das, genau da, wo man es erwartet hat, es siedelt sich an zwischen 2080 und 2080
Ti.
Wo wird sich eigentlich, wo ungefähr würde sich eigentlich meine 1080 Ti ansiedeln?
Hier so eher, he?
Hier so wahrscheinlich.
Hä, warum würde er die Grafikkarte beeinträchtigen, wenn er Screen Capture macht?
Einfach irgendeine Capture-Karte dran und gut ist?
Was aber auch an einem sehr taktfreudigen Speicher liegt, den konnte ich nämlich auf
2000 MHz übertakten, normalerweise liegt der Takt bei dem GDDR6-Speicher dieser Grafikkarte
bei 1750 MHz.
In Remnant von die Ashes in 1440p liegt die 3060 Ti fast auf RTX 2080 Ti Niveau, mit Overclocking
können wir die 3060 Ti sogar über die 2080 Ti bewegen, das war auf jeden Fall sehr, sehr
spannend zu sehen.
Die Minimum FPS liegen interessanterweise bei allen Karten ungefähr im gleichen Bereich.
Erst beim Wechsel auf 4K mit maximalen Details sehen wir hier einen deutlichen Unterschied
zwischen den Karten, vor allem in den Minimum FPS.
Auch hier hilft Overclocking bei der 3060 Ti wieder spürbar, mit einem FPS-Zuwachs von
über 10%.
Das ist gar nicht mal, wollte ich gerade sagen, das ist gar nicht mal so wenig, ne?
Mit Overclocking landen wir auch hier wieder auf 2080 Ti Niveau.
Ich weiß für die meisten ist es schon tot, für mich ist es immer noch mein Lieblingsgame,
deswegen schauen wir uns auch wieder PUBG an mit eSports-Einstellungen, sowohl in 4K
als auch 1440p.
Läuft ja richtig gut, PUBG hat auch so den Ruf absolut kacke zu laufen.
Wobei man halt auch sagen muss, es ist vielleicht ein bisschen so wie in Warzone, wenn du Warzone
mit 80-90 FPS spielst, fühlt sich das auch an wie andere Games mit 30 so.
In 4K liegt die Leistung ungefähr auf dem Level der 2080 und in 1440p knapp hinter der
RTX 3070.
Zum Schluss schauen wir uns jetzt auch wieder auf Control und Playtracing und mit maximalen
Details ist das Spiel nach wie vor unfassbar krass fordernd.
In 1440p würde ich sagen, braucht man mindestens eine 3080, um das wirklich gut zu spielen
und in 4K haben selbst die 3080 und die 3090 Mühe, brauchbare FPS zu liefern.
Das muss man sagen, optisch war Control echt cool, aber Control ist das erste Remedy-Game,
was ich nicht durchgespielt habe, weil ich es zu langweilig fand.
Mit der 3060 Ti definitiv keine Chance hier in 4K und maximalen Details mit RTX On.
Wie erwartet positioniert sich die 3060 Ti zwischen der 2080 und 2080 Ti.
Krass finde ich, dass sich bei dieser Karte der Speicher wirklich sehr sehr gut takten
lässt und zusammen mit dem GPU lässt sich hier eine Zusatzperformance von 10-12% rausholen
und das ist bei Grafikkarten meiner Meinung nach schon wirklich viel, gerade weil bei
diesen Karten ja die Leistungsaufnahme nicht so krass steigt, wir können ja maximal 12%
über das originale Power Target gehen, das heißt, wenn da mal wieder alles lieferbar
ist und ich wirklich endlich mal meinen neuen Rechner zusammenbaue, ich glaube ich bleib
bei der 3090, einfach weil es geht und weil es geht.
Ja maximal 12% mehr Leistungsaufnahme für 12% mehr Leistung, ich denke mal das ist
ein auf jeden Fall fairer Trade, das kann man auf jeden Fall machen, ansonsten diese
Karte sehr sehr gut, was jetzt das reine Design betrifft, wenn man die Karte so verwenden
möchte, wie sie eben ist.
Es ist ganz klar, wie bei der 3090 schon, wenn ihr mit dem Gedanken spielt, ich möchte
vielleicht irgendwann mal auf Wasserkühlung umbauen, dann ist diese Karte definitiv die
falsche Wahl, weil entweder wird es gar keine Wasserkühlungsböcke erst für die geben,
bei 3060 generell so ein bisschen so ein Thema, weil es ja eine günstigere Karte ist,
da gibt es generell schon sehr sehr wenig, gar nichts und bei so einer Karte, die dann
durch die Stromanschlüsse eben eher nicht dafür gemacht ist, wenn ihr eine 3060 haben
wollt, 3060Ti und spielt mit dem Gedanken, die später irgendwann mal Wasser zu kühlen,
vermeidet diese Karte, wenn ihr wisst, ihr wollt es auf jeden Fall niemals tun und die
soll so laufen und bleiben, wie sie ist, ist die Karte eine sehr sehr gute Wahl, ist sehr
günstig.
Ja, ich würde es auch nicht wasserkühlen, ich bin kein Wasserkühlungsfan, da hätte man
noch Wärmelightpads unterbringen können, ansonsten kann ich die Karte auf jeden Fall
absolut empfehlen.
Ich finde es immer noch lustig, dass Gigabyte nach wie vor den Seriennummernsticker auf
der Backplate hat, ich meine, man kann quasi die Garantie durch die Backplate vertauschen
und ich also als Hersteller kann ich es nicht verstehen, warum man das macht, als Endkunde
ist es natürlich genial.
Der Chet hat uns schon erklärt, woran das liegt, der Chet hat uns eben gerade erklärt,
da ist man gesetzlich dazu verpflichtet, es außen anzubringen.
Ich hatte die Backplate nehmen auf die andere Schrauben und habe die Garantie quasi übertragen,
aber vielleicht denkt Gigabyte dann nochmal drüber nach, ob das so schlau ist und ob das
so optisch ist.
Der Chet ist halt wieder feifett heute.
Ja, damit bedanke ich mich fürs Zuschauen, wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal wieder, bis
dann.
Exquisite, so muss das sein.
Ja, da machen wir immer gute Videos, vor allem auch als Übersicht wirklich gut geeignet,
wenn ich jetzt sagen würde, hey, ich brauche eine Mittelklasse Grafikkarte, dann wüsste
ich jetzt, ok, kann ich mir bedenkenlos kaufen, vor allem auch in einem System, weil ich nicht
wasserkühlen will, top.
Der Auer, so, schauen wir uns jetzt an.
Sack, Technikideen für Weihnachten, der neue 11, ok, das ist Gigabyte, der ist mir schon
ein paar Mal aufgefallen, dass die Videos echt ein bisschen Gigabyte sind, wahrscheinlich
geht es 2 Minuten über diese Sache und 11 Minuten über was anderes.
Mach mal den Test, was ist das denn, Datenscham?
Ok, was ist das, Datenscham, Alter, ok, das klingt schon, das machen wir mal aus der VM,
Datenscham.
So, hast du Igor Video vom Bauer gesehen, ja, habe ich, ich habe mich da schon ein bisschen
drüber lustig gemacht, dass 2020 sogar Technik-Youtuber Beef haben, ok, Check starten, zeig her, welchen
Browser benutzt du hauptsächlich, Chrome, Chrome, Chromium, Chromium, Chromium, man
kann den Opera GX Gaming Browser gar nicht ankreuzen, RGB, only RGB Browser, welche
Suchtmaschine benutzt du hauptsächlich, ja, ehrlich gesagt, hauptsächlich Google, aber
immer, immer vermehrter DuckDuckGo, aber hauptsächlich Google, Metagear, verwende das noch jemand,
Bling, äh Bing, Alter, wisst ihr, was das einzige Feature ist, was ich von Bing verwende,
der Daily Hintergrund für meine Linux, das kommt, das kommt Bing, Bing Daily Image, das
ist das einzige, was ich von Bing verwende, hauptsächlich Google, aber immer, immer öfter
DuckDuckGo, so, wie oft löschst du die Cookies im Browser, ja, selten, also eigentlich fast
nie, aber ich mach manchmal, wenn ich Sachen öffne, wo ich weiß, dass ich nicht will,
dass die das irgendwas speichern, mach ich Privacy Session, aber selten, Private Tabs,
so, welchen Cloud-Speicher benutzt du hauptsächlich, Lul, äh Nextcloud, ja, wobei halt Nextcloud
eigentlich keine Cloud im eigentlichen Sinne ist, die heißt bloß so, so, äh, Alter, I
am jinxed, LOL, 5 Monate, Subscription, danke schon für den Sub, hast du einen PGP, hab ich,
hab ich, verwende ich aber nicht, verschlüsselt keine Mails, weil ich keine Mails mehr schicke,
also ich schicke vielleicht zwei Mails im Jahr oder so, ähm, aber ja, ich hab einen PGP-Key,
aber benutze ihn nicht, äh, ist da eine, ja, ja, aber sowas von, alles, welchen Messenger
benutzt du hauptsächlich, Discord, steht hier nicht drin, Discord und Teams steht beides
nicht drin, WhatsApp hab ich noch nie installiert gehabt, auch nicht installiert, auch nicht
installiert, auch nicht installiert, äh, Signal hatte ich mal installiert, weil, als
wir auf der Arbeit Probleme hatten mit Teams, haben wir mal gesagt, wir machen das über
Signal und Signal ist so ein Ding, ne, das ist übelster Crap, allein schon deswegen,
du meldest dich an und sagst, nein, ich möchte nicht, du sagst explizit, ich möchte nicht
mein Adressbuch, mein Adressbuch sharen, was macht Signal, schick trotzdem allen Leuten,
die du im Adressbuch hast, ähm, oder besser gesagt, die dich im Adressbuch haben, eine
Nachricht, dass du jetzt auf Signal bist, wollen die mich verarschen, das geht keinem
was an, die sollen, sollen die Leute in Ruhe lassen, kack Software, Alter, so, welches
Social Media Kanal nutzt du hauptsächlich Twitter, Twitter und YouTube, Twitter, Twitter,
YouTube ist ja so halb Social Media, äh, YouTube ist ja so halb Social Media, Twitter
ist hauptsächlich Social Media, was ich verwende, Telegram macht das auch, es sackt
alles, wie viele Netze hast du bei Amazon, ja, neun von zehn, ab und zu kommt mal irgendwie
was anderes, aber eigentlich ist fast alles Amazon, wie oft liest du Netzpolitik gar
nicht, oder selten, manchmal ist irgendwas verlinkt, verlinkt, verlinktes, ja, Score
erreichten, oh, okay, mein Privacy Score ist 52 von 100, du bist ein Datenschutzschweinehund,
aha, okay, alles klar, na wahrscheinlich, weil ich ein BGP Key, BGP Key hab, by the way,
ich will übrigens nicht spenden, warum soll ich spenden, für was, warum genau sollte ich
jetzt da spenden, so ein Ding hast du programmiert in drei Stunden, excellent, schauen was der
Worst Case ist, wollen wir noch mal gucken, okay, wir versuchen jetzt mal den höchsten
Score zu bekommen, also wir verwenden Chrome, oder, Chrome oder Edge, was ist schlechter
für Datenschutz, okay, Safari vielleicht sogar, Chrome, wir nehmen Chrome, also wir
versuchen mal High Score hinzukriegen, Chrome, welche sucht man, Google, da war ich glaube
ich schon ganz gut mit Google, da war ich wahrscheinlich schon ganz gut mit Google,
so, nie, welchen Cloud Speicher verwendest du, Google Drive, oder, Google Drive ist bestimmt
nochmal, ist doch nochmal schlimmer, nein, natürlich nicht, wer hat sowas schon, nein,
okay, High Score, High Score Run, teuren ist das jetzt, welchen Messenger benutzt du natürlich
den Facebook Messenger, oder WhatsApp, WhatsApp, oder, WhatsApp, was ist schlechter, WhatsApp
oder Facebook Messenger, ist WhatsApp und Facebook Messenger nicht das gleiche mittlerweile,
Facebook, ja was jetzt Chat, WhatsApp, Facebook, ich glaube das nimmt sich nicht, komm wir
machen WhatsApp, welche Social Media Kanal benutzt du hauptsächlich, TikTok, oder, ich
glaube Snapchat, was, Facebook, Facebook, was, was gibt, was gibt die meisten Negativpunkte,
TikTok oder Facebook, oder, Snapchat, Snapchat für, für, für Dickpics, die sich angeblich
selbst löschen, TikTok, okay, wie viel der an letzten Bestellung, alle, nie, Score errechnen,
ah, jetzt, wir haben es geschafft Leute, okay, es ist nicht High Score, es ist Low Score,
aber wir haben es, wir haben es geschafft, World First, okay, Auswertung, Null Punkte,
Null Punkte, Null Punkte, Null Punkte, Null Punkte, Null, oh, ich hätte Facebook, ich
hätte doch Facebook Messenger nehmen müssen Leute, da haben wir, haben wir schon überlegt,
aber, haben es nicht gefunden, ja, TikTok, sehr gut, Rest haben wir, Rest haben wir gut
gemacht, ja, okay, also, da schauen wir uns doch mal, den neuesten Rechner von, wie spricht
man den eigentlich aus, Revinsight, oder, Re-Win-Sight, oder, oder, oder, Revi, Revi-N-Sight,
Re-Win-Sight, Re-Win-Sight, alles klar, so, Zeit war her, ah, yes, sehr gutes Intro, ja,
ja, ja, ja, lang ist es her, wirklich lang ist es her, aber jetzt geht es endlich wieder
weiter mit kreative Fragen, das heißt ab jetzt gibt es auch endlich wieder Freitags
Cringe, ich sag doch, das ist G-Bait, der beschäftigt sich überhaupt nicht mit dem
Rechner, ich kenne das wieder, die Dinge hatten wir schon öfters, das geht jetzt 30 Sekunden
um diesen Rechner und dann über irgendwelche anderen Sachen, so sieht es aus, Alter, ja,
okay, ja, Moment, der hat ja auch nicht den neuen Gaming-PC, weil der einen neuen Gaming-PC
braucht, der hat den Gaming-PC, weil einer mit ihm irgendeine Promotion-Geschichte abgeschlossen
hat, der braucht doch keinen neuen Gaming-PC, das ist da eher so, du bekommst von uns einen
neuen Gaming-PC und du bekommst noch 20.000 Euro für die Werbung für den Gaming-PC obendrauf,
ich glaube noch nicht mal, dass es Content ist, jetzt macht es einfach Promotion für
Monster-PC, oder Caseking, Caseking, also um das ganz kurz zu machen, bei der Leistung,
die Revincite so in seinem Rechner hatte bis jetzt, wäre ein Upgrade meiner Meinung nach
gar nicht notwendig gewesen, aber Caseking dachten sich so, ich meine, es sieht cool
aus, muss man ja mal sagen, es sieht schon cool aus, die RGB-Geschichte und die Wasserkühlung,
mein Fall ist es nicht, ich brauche weder einen Rechner, der leuchtet wie meine Lampe
an der Decke, noch bin ich Fan von Wasserkühlung, also natürlich, wenn einer sagt, Max, wir
geschenken dir das, dann bin ich so, ja okay, warum nicht, aber, haben wollen, nö.
An Weihnachten machen wir doch noch mal ein bisschen Werbung, und so haben sie ihn mit
diesem PC zu seinem Geburtstag überrascht, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, und
so im Detail reden sie auch gar nicht so viel über den PC, ein paar leistungstragende Komponenten
nennen sie, deshalb habe ich mal versucht das Ganze so ein bisschen zu analysieren.
Als CPU hat Caseking hier den AMD Ryzen 9 5950X verbaut.
Das 5000, okay, ja, das ist das Ding, was ich mir auch an meinem neuen Rechner fast eingebaut
hätte, hätte ich ihn gekauft, aber wahrscheinlich kaufe ich jetzt eher einen 5900, weil die
paar mehr Kerne bringt es ja gar nicht.
16 Kerne, 32 Threads und mittlerweile auch eine brachiale Stingelcore-Performance, weil
der ist wirklich gut.
Der ist wirklich gut.
Es ist das, der perfekte Prozessor für ihn, denn der Rechner soll natürlich nicht nur
geile Gamingleistung liefern, sondern das Ganze auch irgendwie noch ins Internet ballern,
vielleicht ein paar Hintergründe.
Aber ganz im Ernst, mit GPU-Encoding brauchst du heute gar keine super mega krasse CPU dafür
mehr.
Und die Quali von GPU-Encoding ist mittlerweile echt okay.
Moment, was zum Geier ist das für ein Ram?
Corsair Dominator?
Moment, der Ram heißt wirklich Dominator, seh ich das jetzt richtig, ja?
Corsair Dominator Platinum, alles klar Leute.
Dominator Platinum.
Corsair Dominator Platinum.
64GB, das ist doch mehr als genug.
64GB, kommt bei mir in den neuen Rechner auch rein.
Ja, aber wenn du Videoschnitt machst, dann können auch 64GB bei 4K-Footage und ein bisschen
Animation und sowas sehr sehr schnell voll werden, ich glaube Robert weiß wovon ich
da spreche.
Über die SSD reden sie in dem Video gar nicht, wenn ich das so richtig gesehen habe,
aber wenn ich diesen PC bauen würde, würde ich mich für eine PCI Express 4.0 SSD, gerade
bei dieser CPU und dieser Plattform entscheiden und da würde ich dann mit der Corsair MP600
gehen.
Ich würde ja gerne endlich mal eine 4TB NVMe-Samsung-SSD einbauen, irgendeine Evo oder so, aber gibt
es ja grad nicht.
Oder gibt es noch?
Gar nicht.
Und als Datengrab kann man dann eine günstigere SATA-SSD oder wer es dann ganz wichtig hat,
der schneidet keine Videos mehr selbst, ne ne, geh ich nicht von aus, der kann sich natürlich
auch noch eine normale Festplatte als Datengrab dazuholen.
Ja und die Grafikkarte, es darf natürlich in diesem Rechner auch keine andere sein,
ist eine RTX 3090 und das ist meiner Meinung nach, auch gerade wenn man so Videoschnitt
macht, streamt und so weiter, eine beste Grafikkarte.
Ja, 3090 würde ich mir auch einbauen jetzt, wenn ich irgendwas Neues bastle.
Grafikkarte, die man zurzeit so kaufen kann, die ist allerdings sehr sehr schwer verfügbar
und leider auch verdammt teuer, aber mit 24GB VRAM, da kann man dann auch nicht so viel
meckern.
Ich meine, in dem vorherigen Rechner hatte er zwei 2080 Ti's, kann das sein?
Beim Mainboard, da reden sie auch gar nicht.
Ja gut, aber SLI ist halt das Sack.
Das ist so ein 800€ Mainboard, oder?
Das ist eigentlich so mit das beste Board, was man auf der X570 Plattform kaufen kann.
Interessant wird es dann aber wirklich bei dem Case, denn das Case ist eigentlich schon
kein PC Case mehr, sondern es ist irgendwie ein Haus, also ich meine, es ist ein Corsair
Obsidian 1000D und da hat er insgesamt 21 QL Lüfter verbaut.
21, warum?
Hebt das ab, kann das fliegen, oder wie?
Ja, Seasonic macht leise Dinger.
So viel erst mal zu den leistungstragenden Komponenten, jetzt kommt aber die Besonderheit
dazu, denn eines muss ich Caseking lassen und an der Stelle mal wirklich Props an Caseking,
die Wasserkühlungssysteme, die die machen, die sind extrem geil, also die beherrschen
in der Hinsicht definitiv ihr Handwerk und die haben da eine sehr, sehr geile Custom-Wasserkühlung
eingebaut.
Cool aussehen tut's.
Mein Fall ist es nicht, ich mag so Ultra-Pling-Pling-PCs nicht, aber cool aussehen tut's, ja.
Also, wenn Sie jetzt selbst sagen, der PC kostet 11.000 Euro, dann müssen wir es...
Na ja, 11.000 Euro macht einfach sich viel besser in den Titel als 5.000 Euro PC.
Stubmorker sagt, ist doch der Horror, wenn man sowas wechseln will.
Das wird nicht gewechselt, da wird einfach neu ein PC hingestellt.
Easy.
Die Wasserkühlung kann ins Geld gehen, aber so viel wie insgesamt die leistungstragenden
Komponenten werden auch die Wasserkühlungsteile nicht unbedingt kosten.
Geil sieht dieses Ding auf jeden Fall aus, für mich wäre es jetzt vielleicht sogar ein
bisschen zu groß.
Ja, für mich ist es total Overkill.
Also, von der Optik her, das ist, wie gesagt, ich bin kein Pling-Pling-PC-Fan.
Das ist wirklich riesen, riesen groß, das muss nicht unbedingt sein und man muss sich
an der Stelle auch fragen, hat Revin Zeit jetzt wirklich schon einen neuen Rechner gebraucht?
Nö.
Aber da braucht Geld von der Promotion.
Vielleicht in 3-4 Jahren gemacht.
Schupfnudel111 fragt, würde es sich lohnen von einer RTX 20-
Okay, das war's.
Okay, ich hab mich ein bisschen verkalkuliert, ich hab gesagt, er redet 30 Sekunden bis 2
Minuten über das Thema, jetzt waren es aber nach der Werbung doch 3 Minuten 30 Sekunden,
alles klar.
Jetzt gucken wir uns nicht an.
Ja, aber sieh, ähnlich.
So, gibt's irgendwelche Battlefield-Sachen, die wir nicht geguckt haben?
Nope.
Anscheinend, anscheinend nicht.
Top 5 Linux-Distros, Raspirinas, Spiel-Tran-Zeug, Technik-Ideen für Weihnachtsgeschenke.
Hm.
Mal gucken.
Wann kommt ein Venis-Unleashed raus, gibt's da schon was genaues, irgendwann Ende des
Jahres, ne?
Release.
Ja, da steht nur Dezember, die sagen nichts genaues.
Wann werden Battlefield 3 Noobs gebashed?
Ja, ich bin mir gar nicht sicher, ob ich das Onstream mache, ich geh dann erst mal Mittagessen
später und dann werd ich ein bisschen Battlefield 3 spielen und vielleicht machen wir das Onstream.
Okay, Technik-Ideen für Weihnachtsgeschenke, dann zeig mal her.
Was ist Venis Unleashed Modding-Tools für Battlefield 3 oder besser gesagt Battlefield
3, gemoddetes Battlefield 3, dass du Custom-Content für erstellen kannst oder auch Parameter
am Game verändern kannst.
Wo ich hoffe, dass das richtig einschlagen wird, das wär auf jeden Fall geil und man
darf nicht vergessen, es wär nicht der erste Mod, der übelst abhebt, ne?
Guckt euch CS an, guckt euch DayZ an oder sowas, was bis heute nicht fertig ist, aber
mit dem Unterschied, dass das Games waren, für die Modding eben Ziel war und Modding
bei Battlefield 3 war nie Ziel.
Gucken deine Arbeitskollegen eigentlich da in Stream?
Der ein oder andere ab und zu, das weiß ich ja, aber die meisten wissen noch nicht,
wann ich sowas hab, aber sowas mache und die meisten geht sowas auch nix an.
Also geht das nix an und interessiert's auch nicht.
Okay, also Technik-Ideen für Weihnachten, exzellent.
So, was ist denn weihnachtlich, ist rotweihnachtlich, ist grünweihnachtlich, oder schläft da gleich
vom Schnee-Ding weihnachtlich, es ist wieder soweit, diese besondere Zeit des Jahres steht
vor der Tür, vielleicht meine Lieblingszeit des Jahres, wo YouTuber versuchen ihre Einnahmen
mit Verkaufsprovisionen aus Geschenkelisten auf billigste Art und Weise...
Okay, wo geht's los?
Wo geht's los?
Ja, hier geht's los.
Ne.
Wo geht's los?
Ein Anchor.
Meint, wo geht's da los?
Geht's hier schon los?
Ich glaube, hier geht's schon los.
Äh, was hältst du vom Lidl Smart Home Zigbee Zeug?
Ich hab mir das letztens im Prospekt tatsächlich mal angeguckt, manche Sachen sahen gar nicht
so kacke aus, aber...
Nö.
Also.
Okay, Bluetooth-Lautsprecher braucht keiner, wobei, wir können uns versparen, ha, wir
gucken uns einfach hier unten die Geschenkeliste an.
Big Brain, da müssen wir uns das Video gar nicht angucken.
Exzellent.
Dann zeig mal her.
Was haben wir denn?
Äh, Bluetooth-Lautsprecher, juckt mich nicht, HomePod Mini braucht keiner, NFC-Text, tatsächlich
NFC-Text sind eine wirklich coole Geschichte.
NFC-Text sind wirklich praktisch, ne, ich sag dazu nur, meine Klo-Automatisierung.
Klo-Automatisierung, Handy an NFC-Tag halten, NFC-Tag, Wlup, NFC-Tag gescannt und Heizer
an.
Exzellent, so muss das sein.
Also, NFC-Tags sind wirklich nice.
Äh, Thermostat, EFTA, das ist irgendwie so ne, so ne proprietäre Dings, äh, Air Purifier
braucht man kein, man kann einfach lüften, kann einfach lüften und gut ist, es sei denn,
es sei denn, man ist allergisch gegen irgendwelche Pollen und möchte das Filtern, aber das brauche
ich nicht, weil da mach ich einfach meine Klimaanlage an, auf, äh, Pollenfilter, Filter-Modus,
die hat sowas eingebaut.
Ein GAN-Netzteil, was ist ein GAN-Netzteil, das ist einfach USB-C, oder, das sind 50
Watt, bisschen klein, GAN, ist GAN, ist GAN das neue Fast Charge oder was ist das, was
ist GAN, ich weiß auch nicht was GAN ist, soll ein GAN sein, Ausgangsleistung, GAN, GAN,
Gallium Nitrit, what, verstehe nicht, inwieweit ist es relevant, bei nem Netzteil, hä, aja,
ok, das wirklich brauche ich nicht, was, 46 Euro, normales Netzteil kostet dann was,
5, ok, ist vielleicht nicht schlecht, kann ich nicht beurteilen, was haben wir sonst
noch, äh, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, ne, die da, die da kommen mir nicht in die Tüte, weil
die lassen sich nicht richtig flashen, ich hab mir so eine Steckdosenleiste von denen
gekauft, und das ist der erste China Hersteller, der aktiv Vorkehrungen, ähm, getroffen hat,
dass man sie nicht flashen kann, und na, das, das kommt mir nicht ins Haus, die anderen
China Hersteller, die haben halt die neueste Firmware, dass sie sich nicht mehr über das,
übers WLAN flashen lässt, aber die haben explizit irgendwas gemacht am Microcontroller, dass
sich das nicht mehr flashen lässt, ja, was fällt denen ein, also die kommen mir nicht
ins Haus, Ikea Zwischenstecker, wird nicht aufgemacht, ähm, Übersicht Zwischenstecker
bitte immer mehr, ne, ich hätte gern Magadena auf USB, Alter, warum ist das so teuer, Kogeek,
jawoll, endlich Kogeek wieder, ne, braucht kein Mensch noch was davon, Zwischenstecker
kaufe ich mir die Vierer Packs, die man flashen kann, wieso geht eigentlich Uplog bei Twitch
nicht mehr, weil die sich grad so einen Wettkampf liefern mit Uplog, wer schafft es seine Werbung
so zu tarnen, dass man sie nicht als Werbung erkennt, und wer erkennt sie, die haben ja
schon vor einer Weile angefangen, YouTube und Twitch Content und Werbung von den gleichen
Servern auszuliefern, so, darauf hin, gingen alle DNS-basierten Adblocker, so wie Piehole
oder Adblock, ne, AdGuard nicht mehr, und, ähm, ja, genau, mittlerweile gibt es auch
wieder Sachen, wo das funktioniert, ja, aber natürlich bin ich nicht für Twitch Adblocking,
da verdiene ich ja weniger, so, ähm, was hat man sonst noch empfohlen, VR-Brille, ne, 3D-Drucker,
ok, der ist tatsächlich gut, die Prusa-Dinger sind tatsächlich ziemlich gut, Kabelbinder,
ja, davon habe ich auch einen Pack, die sind wirklich nützlich, also, nicht exakt die,
aber so ähnliche Klettverschluss-Kabelbinder, die sind wirklich nice, ne, er hat am Anfang
gesagt, die YouTuber versuchen das zu pushen, und dann hat er glaube noch gesagt, dass er
das jetzt auch macht, irgendwie sowas, ist auch egal, wen juckt's, ja, so die Kabelbinder
sind tatsächlich ganz nützlich, und ansonsten, VR-Brille juckt mich nicht, ne, ok, nix großartiges
dabei, oh, was hat er für ein Temperatursensor als Empfehlung, ne, ne, ne, also für Temperaturanzeige
habe ich hier mein eigenes selbstgebasteltes Teil, was hier rumsteht, aber, ähm, Temperatursensor
würde ich, irgendwo andere Kombi nehmen, ne, also, ist jetzt für mich nix großartig
dabei, ok, YouTube, was empfiehlst du uns heute, also YouTube möchte unbedingt, dass
wir uns dieses Video angucken, weil das haben die schon, bei jedem Refresh empfehlen die
das, aber, warum, weil, mein, es ist, es ist halt ne 1 HE-Kiste mit 12 Einschüben, was
ist, das ist ja nix Tolles, Fiber Optics, ok, zeig mal her, Fiber Optics, ich brauch,
ich brauch Rechenzentrum im, im, im Dunkeln, nop, gibt's nicht, gebated Video, HomePod
Mini würde ich mir auch nie kaufen, ja, generell, alles Sachen, die, so auf einen Hersteller
gemünzt sind, hol ich mir nicht, ich bin bei einem Home Assistant Setup wirklich zufrieden,
Redstar OS Installation Review, nö, das ist langweilig, das ist ultra langweilig, Redstar
OS, das ist irgendein uralt Redhead Fork, ok, nix, nix interessantes, nix interessantes,
nix interessantes, nix interessantes, Firewall Explains, nix interessantes, nix interessantes,
nix interessantes, ist der HomePod Mini echt so kacke, ich hab keine Ahnung, ob der kacke
oder gut ist, aber wie gesagt, ich hol mir nix, was so auf, auf, auf einen, einen spezifischen
Hersteller irgendwie ist und, und sonst nix funktioniert, was das, zeig mal her, Knäherbeer,
Knäherüberwachung durch BND, oh, das ist mir jetzt zu BigBrain, der Content, Kubernetes
Drop Docker Support, stand das da irgendwo, die haben, die haben, die haben aber den,
ja, hier, Kubernetes Dropping Docker Support, ne, ich glaube, die droppen Docker Support
gar nicht, was, lass mal überlegen, was haben die, was, was machen die, vielleicht droppen
die Docker File Support oder irgendwie so, keine Ahnung, aber Docker Support an sich,
Docker führt ja, Docker hat ja gar keinen eigenen Docker Container mehr, das sind ja
alles mittlerweile standardisiertes Container Format und darauf basieren ja auch die ganzen
Kubernetes Container, also ich weiß gar nicht, was die da droppen, vielleicht, dass
die keine Docker Runtime mehr unterstützen oder so, was aber auch okay ist, braucht man
eh nicht, do not buy this cheap, irgendwie habe ich den Eindruck, dass es mittlerweile
eine komplett eigene Kategorie gibt auf YouTube, ich bestelle bei Wish und zeige dann, wie
scheiße das Produkt ist, dabei sollte man eigentlich schon defaultmäßig von ausgehen,
dass wenn man bei Wish bestellt, man irgendeinen Scam Crap kriegt, außerdem, wie ich schon
total oft gesagt habe, nur extreme Kacknoobs, die sich für schlau halten, bestellen bei
Wish, niemand bestellt bei Wish, der noch normal im Kopf ist, jemand, der normal im
Kopf ist und was günstig haben will, bestellt in China genau das, was er braucht und alle
anderen Kacknoobs bestellen bei Amazon, also wer bestellt bei Wish, genug, ich weiß, aber
ich verstehe nicht mal, warum, oh da fackelt, MonkaS Smoke, was ist das, wow, was macht
der da, ist das schon Sylvester, was muss man dafür machen, anstatt 12 Volt, 24 Volt
reinhauen oder was, das ist aber ein richtig Oldschooling, ist das da unten noch ein AGP
oder was ist das, das ist ein richtig antikes uralt Board hier, aber guck mal, das ist auch
von 2013, it smells like Nvidia, ok, wenn man schon die Grafikkarten herstellt anhand
des Geruchs erkennt nicht schlecht, das sind Cocomodates oder, hör mal, what the hell,
ja, ja, da sind Cocomodates, oh fuck, es fängt noch an zu brennen, was haben die da gemacht,
ach hier, siehste, ich lag gar nicht so falsch mit, anstatt 12 Volt, 24 Volt oder sonst was
anderes auf das Mainboard, ja, Afterburner aktiviert, ja, jetzt vorbei, abgefackelt,
oh, oh, wo, ok, damit hätte ich das nicht gerechnet, boah, das glüht ja richtig, ey,
und jetzt zum Hersteller zurückschicken oder bei Amazor zurückschicken, ne, können sie
ja nicht, das ist so alt, das ist auch nicht von 2013 das Board, das ist eher so ein Board
von 2004 oder so oder 5, ok, das Verge Bild, PC Bild, das hat ja wirklich riesen Runden
gezogen, gut, YouTube hat sich jetzt gedacht, das müssen wir uns angucken, alles klar, excellent,
aber es ist ja in den YouTube Empfehlungen wirklich nur Crap dabei, was ist da los,
also selten so schlecht YouTube Empfehlungen gab, wie gestern und heute, aber das Raspberry
Pinas ist glaube ich übelst langweilig, das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an, wir gucken
uns jetzt, wir gucken uns jetzt Mario 64, Speedrun, Stratz, neue Stratz an, excellent, is it possible,
ne, it's possible to beat Mario 64 Allstars mit einem Stern, ok, zeig her, oh, yes, but
over the years, Speedrunners have been able to lower that requirement from 70 stars down
to 50, to 31, to 16, to 1, to 0, this is accomplished by skipping past star doors, which require
a specific amount of power stars to open, primarily by using one of the most infamous
exploits in gaming history, the backwards game job, or the BLJ for short, gut, ich meine,
das schockt ja mittlerweile keinen mehr, das hat ja jeder schon mal gesehen, also jeder
der schon ein bisschen Speedruns guckt, er kennt das ja, ist Speedrun noch erlaubt auf,
warum nicht, es gibt riesige Events auf Twitch, warum sollte das nicht erlaubt sein, oh Gott,
die Leute haben Probleme, Alter, Lachia, du darfst mir solche Sachen nicht schicken,
ey, oh Mann, oh Gott, ey, ich muss, ich muss das jetzt zeigen, ey, so, also sie haben jetzt
den Tag blind playthrough removed, weil das Leute triggern könnte, die Plinzen wahrscheinlich,
inclusive language, oh Mann, oh, Pains Champ, okay, ich wusste nicht, dass das so viele
Leute triggert, hätte nicht gedacht, dass das Wort blind playthrough Leute triggert,
okay, ja, Welt gerettet, die haben echt Probleme teilweise, so, okay, wir gucken jetzt einfach,
ich sag nichts dazu, am besten, am besten war immer noch Leute, Moment, Moment, wo wir
gerade beim Thema sind, das beste Ticket war, also der beste Sache war immer noch,
da kann es vielleicht noch einer dran erinnern,
also es ging, es war letztes Jahr schon, es war letztes Jahr schon, also es ging darum,
die haben, das war übrigens ein übelstes Trollcomment, weil der Typ hat sich auch gleich
gelöscht, die haben ein, hier, guck mal, da unten ist es, da unten ist es, die haben
sich drüber aufgeregt, dass Whistle Studio Code so eine Mütze gemacht hat, weil das
ist ja offensive, dass da ein Christmas Head drin ist, man darf auch gesehen, man konnte
das in der Option garantiert ausschalten und mal ganz ehrlich, wer davon echt offended
ist, der hat einfach Pech gehabt, ja, der sollte mal eher an sich arbeiten und nicht
wegen jedem Scheiß offended sein, anstatt irgendwelche GitHub Issues aufzumachen, zumindest
haben die da ewig drüber diskutiert, das Ding ist, Moment, Moment, die haben es sogar
schon gelockt, ja, so und, aber was viel witziger ist, wisst ihr was Microsoft dann gemacht
hat, ich fand's eigentlich richtig, richtig, richtig poggers die Antwort von Microsoft
und zwar, die haben das ersetzt durch eine Schneeflocke dann, fand ich eigentlich lustig,
natürlich waren die Leute dann noch mehr getriggert danach, die haben dann den Santa Head durch
eine Schneeflocke ersetzt und da waren die Leute immer noch getriggert, die hatten echt
reine Güte, ich war echt froh, als Technik oder Technologieprojekte und solche Sachen
noch von dieser Sache noch verschont geblieben sind, ja, oh man, tja, so ist es halt, okay
wir gucken uns am besten mal das Video an.
Da muss man ja sagen, mit dieser 3D Mario Collection hat sich Nintendo überhaupt keine
Mühe gegeben.
Oh, oh, what the fuck, ah, yes, ist
es laut genug oder soll ich ein bisschen lauter machen, so genau so hätte ich es auch probiert,
ja, naja, oh of
Mario enters the castle after skipping the key to here
Warum kann er denn warum kann er denn so krass hoch springen an der stelle?
Let's get started
At the start mario enters the castle after skipping. Alter warum kann er hier drei kilometer hoch springen?
Hier mario was faced with his first major obstacle the eight star door
Das door leads to the first bowser level. Ja stimmt das ist das ist was was du halt als normaler mensch input nicht machen kannst
Es ist ein klick um den gebäude zu accessieren
In der original version kann diese star door durchschnittlich durch einen hyperspeed durch einen hyperspeed
unter einem hohen schluss in einem piller neben dieser stelle
Von dort kann mario aus der stelle nach oben nach oben nach rechts durch die stelle
Aber da wir nicht hyperspeed mit bljs auf shindou bauen können, müssen wir eine andere Methode finden, um das zu tun
Um das so schnell wie möglich zu erreichen, entlang der Tasse entlang der Bob-omb-Battle-Field
Das macht nicht viel Sinn anfangs, da man hier nicht sogar einen Star in einem 1-Star-Speed-Rumpf holt
Aber dieses Teil der Routen ist eigentlich ziemlich wichtig
Hier in Bob-omb-Battle-Field gibt es einen Ort, wo Mario die Geschwindigkeit, die durch die Stelle durch die Stelle verbraucht werden kann
Und es kann hier auf der rechten Seite von diesem Rock auf der rechten Seite der Stelle gefunden werden
Spezifisch dieses Schlauch
Dies ist ein schlappiges Schlauch
Ein Type 0x13 Schlauch
Und es ist der Hauptkomponent für eine Technik genannt C-Up-Hyperspeed
Wenn du den Schlauch drüber drückst
Wie viele Tricks gibt es in Mario 64 eigentlich?
5.000? Ah, ja!
Aha!
Excellent!
Ah, ja!
Ah, natürlich! Na klar, der Zaun! Logisch!
Was zur Hölle?
Ah, ja!
Alles klar! Alles klar!
Mario riecht der Hacker-Man!
Warte!
Wie er einfach mal von dem Schild abspringt
Ich mein, er ist ein falsches Wort, weil das ist ja automatischer Input
Exit, ja
Das machen die normalerweise auch
Übrigens, ich hab irgendwo mal da ein paar Erklärungen zugelesen
Du brauchst diese Schlüssel, weil sonst die nächste Zone im Schloss nicht geladen wird
Also sprich, das Schloss ist in drei Zonen eingeteilt
Keller, Erdgeschoss, Dach
Und wenn man diese Schlüssel nicht verwendet oder nicht durch die Türen geht
Dann ist dahinter einfach nichts geladen
Das heißt, man muss zwingend die Bowser-Level machen
Ah, alles klar!
Genau so hätt ich's auch gemacht
Was?
Alter!
Ist ja gut!
Alles klar! Alles klar!
Blub blub blub blub
Das hat mich früher, wo ich das auf Man 4.60 gespielt hab, schon immer gewonnen
Das ist so ultra ruckelt in dem Level
Moment, wie ist denn das hochgekommen?
Ah, ja, alles klar!
Ah, ja!
Einfach mal an die Wand gesprungen, so muss das sein
Die Musik, äh
Ja
Alter!
Machen die das jetzt bei jeder Tür oder was?
Eine halbe Stunde im Kreis, hüpfen und dann durch die Tür kleppen
Da wird's ja echt schlecht bei!
Gut, ja!
Ja gut, das ist ja nichts Neues jetzt, das kriegen wir alles gebacken
Ja, alles klar!
Okay, man muss einfach nur, also wir wissen jetzt, easy einfach immer nur gegen die Wand springen und irgendwann kleppt man durch die Tür
Also kann sie einfach
Das wird
Ja
Kennst du dich zufällig mit GPS Struckern aus? Nee
Ja, okay, das ist ja im Prinzip immer das gleiche jetzt
Mein, es dauert zwar ewig, es dauert zwar ewig bis du das geskriptet hast
Excellent!
Ja, das ist echt so ein Speedrun-Porn
Aber nice, nice
Das ist eh ein guter Channel, die haben viele interessante Speedrun-Geschichten
Was, man kann Mario Odyssey? Ah, almost, almost
Ohne Cappy, weil ganz ohne Cappy wird es nicht funktionieren
Du brauchst ja Cappy, damit du in manchen Levels über diese, ja wie heißt das, diese, diese, diese, diese
Seile rüberfliegen kannst
Und da sind ja auch Ladezonen und sowas dabei, also das wird man wahrscheinlich nicht ganz ohne Cappy hinbekommen
Okay, du selbst bei die Pi-NAS interessiert mich ehrlich gesagt jetzt gerade nicht, zeig mal her
Top 5 Linux, das ist viel zu lang
Also, ganz ehrlich, man kann es ganz einfach machen
Top Linux-Distro für Beginners, meiner Meinung nach das da
Wenn einer einfach will, einfach Linux Mint installieren und sich das Ganze erstmal angucken
Nach Möglichkeit XFCE oder sonst was, wenn sie in der VM ist und gut ist
Manjaro finde ich für Einsteiger nicht wirklich gut, Ubuntu finde ich für Einsteiger auch nicht wirklich gut
Linux Mint ist ja ein Ubuntu mit ein bisschen, oder Debian mittlerweile, ich weiß gar nicht
Mit ein bisschen Gedöns dabei
Das ist Elementary, das finde ich jetzt, ja, da muss man, man muss die Elementary, den Elementary-Way mögen
Was das hier ist, weiß ich gar nicht
Was ist das?
Was ist das für Linux? Ich weiß es nicht
Sagt das Logo, sagt mir nichts
Ich kenne das einer von euch
Sagt mir nichts, keine Ahnung
Was ist der Unterschied zwischen Debian und Ubuntu?
Im Prinzip ist in Ubuntu ein Debian mit ein paar anderen angepassten Sachen
Ja, und zum Beispiel auch Repos, dass du Treiber installieren kannst, die nicht rein Open Source sind
Und ein paar Anpassungen wie, dass man Netzwerk-Config in YAML machen soll und sowas
Du hast, Ubuntu hast du ein bisschen neuere Pakete als in Debian
Zum größten Teil ist der Unterschied jetzt nicht so groß zwischen Debian und Ubuntu
Peppermint OS, okay, haben wir glaube ich noch nie ausprobiert, hatte ich auch noch nicht vor
Max sehe ich da Battlelog, geht da was? Ja, ich habe vorhin geguckt
Und zwar, ich habe vorhin geguckt, welche Battlefield 3 Surfer belegt sind
Weil Battlefield 3 ist ja gerade kostenlos
Da habe ich mir gedacht, guckst du mal und es sind erstaunlich viele Server schon voll
Oh ne, ne, ne, please, please, nicht diese Copypasta, nein, nein, nein, nein, geh weg
Nicht das Ding, Alter
Aber ich finde es schön, dass du eine deutsche Übersetzung davon gefunden hast
So, wir gucken jetzt noch das andere Speedrun Video, was ich hier offen hatte, das da
Das wollte ich mir nämlich die ganze Zeit schon angucken
Ja
Die 100% Kategorie
Das kennt man ja
Ich glaube, ich habe noch nie eine Low-Percent-Run irgendwo geguckt
Ja, nicht unbedingt
Kommt auf das Game mal, will ich sagen
Ich muss euch sagen, ich finde den Breath of the Wild-Speedrun mega langweilig
Das ist kein gescheites Speedrun-Game
Ne, Pokemon ist nicht, wo wirklich meinst, müsste ich da Frasier angucken
Kennst du Speedrun-Dale? Ja, da war sogar der Tylo mal, mit dem habe ich ja auch davor ein Video zu Mario 64 aufgenommen
Okay
Also sprich, wenn einer drei, fünf oder zehn Jahre braucht für einen Speedrun, aber es sind weniger Sachen, die er einsammelt, ist er Weltrekordhalter
Exzellent
Ist der neue PC schon am Start?
Nö, ich habe aber doch gar keinen neuen PC bestellt, weil wie gesagt, hardwaremäßig brauche ich es nicht
Und ich warte erstmal, bis die Teile wieder verfügbar sind bzw. zu normalen Preisen verfügbar sind
Warum greift den der Gegner nicht an?
Was für Teile willst du ja haben? Wahrscheinlich einen 3900X oder einen 3950X, aber wahrscheinlich einen 3900X, eine 3090 und 64G RAM
Und eigentlich eine 4TB M2 SSD, aber da gibt es keine gescheitene, die haben wir aktuell
Das ist die Extended Copypasta davon, oder?
Achja, ist ja klar, alles logisch
Äh, Moment, habe ich 3900X gesagt? Ich meine 5900X, nicht 3900X
Ich habe mich von 5900X gemeint, aber warum sollte ich jetzt noch einen alten Ryzen kaufen?
Okay, ich glaube mal ganz im Ernst, da musste ganz schön hart im Leben sein, dass du einen 25 Stunden Speedrun machst
Speed, Speed, Speedrun by the way, 25 Stunden
Darf man mal so was pausen machen? Klar, darfst du pausen machen, kein Problem, aber du musst halt einen Timer weiter laufen lassen
Oh, jetzt kommen irgendwelche Big Prank Glitches gleich, ich sehe es schon kommen
Ja, jetzt verstehe ich auch den Titel
Jetzt verstehe ich auch den Titel, die nutzen diesen Glitch jetzt wahrscheinlich um irgendwo durchzuklippen und das dauert halt 17 Stunden
Okay, Champ
Ah, Nintendo hat es verkackt, Anzeige ist raus, Refund ist beantragt
Geil
Was denkst du was der fertig pc kosten wird, irgendwas um 4000€ glaube ich.
Ich hatte es mal grob überschlagen.
Okay das ist, das ist verdammt langsam.
Deswegen stehen die auch 17 Stunden rum.
Das ist fast so langsam wie die Telekom.
représentiert will сек viewed
och genau!
Da kann ich mich dran erinnern.
Extrem nervig
am schlimmsten war es in Windwaker
wo du
wenn du auf eine neue
gekommen bist, wo der immer angefangen hat, die kleinsten Kack-Items hochzuhalten.
Obwohl ich Windbreaker eigentlich ganz gut fand. Ich fand es eigentlich exakt, Windbreaker fand ultra nice.
Wird ja nicht so, wird ja eigentlich nicht so gerne, gerne...
Also es gilt ja als eines der schlechtesten Zelda-Games, aber ich fand Windbreaker, äh, nicht Windbreaker, nicht Windbreaker. Sorry Leute, ich meine nicht Windbreaker, ich mein...
Skyward Sword, nicht Windbreaker, wie komm ich auf Windbreaker, alter. Skyward Sword fand ich übelst nice.
Ich weiß, ähm, was ja eigentlich allgemein hin so als eines der schlechtesten Zelda-Games so gilt, aber ich fand Skyward Sword richtig spockers.
Nicht Windbreaker. Windbreaker ist ja nur unbestreitbar als der, der besseren, ja.
Also, war am Anfang auch nicht so, aber mittlerweile...
Ich, Windbreaker dürfte eigentlich neben Ocarina of Time mit das beliebteste sein.
Auch was Speedrun-Sachen angeht.
4 zu 3 Spiele in 2020.
3 Spiele in 2020.
4 Spiele in 2020.
Exzellent! Das muss bestimmt äußerst spannend sein.
Speedrun, by the way.
Ruppysliding wurde zuerst in der Arbiter's Grounds Dungeon ausprobiert, um den Infamous Po Gate zu skippen.
Normalerweise muss man in der ersten Part des Dungeons vier Po-Souls bekommen, um den Gate zu öffnen und in die zweite Part zu gehen.
Die Any%-Speedrun kann einen von diesen Po-Souls skippen und den Gate trotzdem öffnen, weil der Gate nur die letzten drei Po-Souls, die man erhält, betrachtet.
Aber mit einem gut positionierten Ruppyslide kannst du die Gate einfach in ein kurzes 13-Hunterspielen durch das Po-Gate skippen.
Dieser Sliding ist besonders langweilig, weil die Arbiter's Grounds mehr als andere Bereiche das Speed-Limit haben.
Mit nur dieses Po-Gate kann Lopurcent ein Mindestens 16-Hunterspielen werden.
Die drei Portale, die Lopurcent skippt, sind das Nordveren-Woods, Death Mountain und Hyrule-Kastletown-Portale.
Die Portale von Deathmountain und North Feren Woods sind ziemlich trivial und geben nur ein paar Minuten.
Skippen die Portale von Hyrule Castle Town macht ein langweiliges Setup, um den Gegner aus den Bänden zu fahren und den Castletown durch den Osten entlang zu kommen.
Skippen diese Portale gibt es ca. 7 Minuten, wenn es gut geht.
Das bleibt uns mit nur den zwei kleinen Schlägen übrig. Eine der kleinen Schläge, die skippt wird, ist in der Snowpeak Mansion.
Sie ist nur ein wenig schneller als die Schläge, weshalb es nicht viel Zeit gibt, wenn es gut geht.
Das bleibt uns mit nur einer kleinen Schläge übrig, die Low Percent skippt.
At this point, skipping the prior 7 things we listed makes the run about 17 hours long, 13 hours of which is spent staring at a blue rupee.
The final small key that leads into this droid is the very first one in the Feren Woods.
This key unlocks the gate to North Feren Woods, but there are conveniently some Bokoblin enemies nearby that can drop blue rupees and allow for a rupee slide through.
So we should just use one of those rupees for a rupee slide, and the small key is easily skipped after a few hours, right?
Well, no.
If we just rupee slide through the gate and continue the game, we have to come back to this area later as Wolf Link.
But rupee slides don't work as Wolf Link, so we'd just be forced to go and get the small key.
We need to come back to North Feren later in the game to access both the Forest Temple and the Sacred Grove for the Gale Boomerang and Master Sword items respectively.
The only way we can skip the Feren Woods small key is if we can somehow get both of these items the first time we reach the area as Human Link.
Unfortunately, the Forest Temple is blocked off by a pair of boulders at the beginning of the game to make sure that players can't access it early.
And you're only supposed to access the Sacred Grove much later in the game after completing the Lakebed Temple.
Thankfully, this problem does have a solution, but it's a very convoluted one.
And it's not.
In Twilight Princess, it's possible to transfer a bomb bag to a new file if you've completed the Midna's Desperate Hour portion of the game on another file already.
You can then use Iza in Upper Zora's River to duplicate bomb bags into Link's inventory and carry them onto the title screen using something called the Bane of Time.
This works fine for low percent in Twilight Princess, because the category only counts the things you collect on the file which finishes the run.
So you just start a new file, speedrun the game up until the point that you can duplicate the bomb bag while collecting whatever items you want, and then transfer a bomb bag onto a new file and continue it from the beginning.
Then, on the new file, you can perform the...
Previously mentioned Rupee Slide to skip the small key in Farron Woods.
Blow up the boulders in front of Forest Temple to enter and obtain the Gale Boomerang.
Use the Gale Boomerang combined with the Long Jump Attack glitch to get into the sacred...
Perform another two and a half hour Rupee Slide to get past the first area and eventually make your way to the Master Sword where you will be greeted by this lovely cutscene.
Once you obtain the Master Sword, you can finally save Talo in front of the Forest Temple and then you can leave North Farron without needing to come back.
And that is the entire convoluted process of skipping this one small key which adds another seven hours to the run.
The total run time is now almost 24 hours and these seventeen of those hours are spent staring at blue Rupees.
Currently only two runners have ever completed a low percent speedrun, Taka and Anorakis.
With Anorakis holding the current world record at 24 hours 59 minutes and 52 seconds.
Obviously, given the length of the low percent speedrun combined with the enormously high cutscene to gameplay ratio, it's not a very popular category.
And the sadistic part...
...wants to let you know that it could be even worse if you want it to be.
There's one more small key located in the City in the Sky dungeon that is technically possible to skip. However, skipping this small key is way beyond just being difficult.
It requires performing multiple frame and position perfect instances of a complicated technique known as Clawshot Actor Displacement.
Using this technique, it's possible to literally rearrange the level geometry of this room in City in the Sky and use the Clawshot with a bunch of precise bomb boosts to gain height and make it to the upper part of the room.
No human has ever successfully performed this skip and it's considered to be TAS only.
But being able to execute this skip would lower the item count by one compared to the two runs that are on the leaderboard.
This means that if someone felt inclined to...
Okay, that's just because Nintendo games are popular. And Nintendo games are just being camped by a lot of people after some glitches.
And it's being tried out and a lot of people are playing it. That's why the things that are being turned off are always being found in Nintendo games.
It's not like Nintendo games are being poorly programmed. It's just that most Nintendo games are being searched after.
At this skip, it wouldn't matter if it took them a week, a month or even a year to skip the small key.
When that run finishes, it would be a world record since nobody before would have completed Twilight Princess with as few things as it did.
It would also simultaneously be the longest, craziest, most difficult and most boring speedrun of Twilight Princess ever done.
Which quite frankly is an impressive combination of traits for a speedrun to have.
This is the current state of Twilight Princess Low%. Whether or not it'll be possible to skip more things in the future is of course unknown.
We'll never truly know what the least amount of things we can beat the game with is, unless the day comes where the number of things drops to zero.
Until then, we make do with what we know to be possible. And in the case of Twilight Princess, where collecting the least amount of things ironically takes the most amount of time, we stare at rupees for over 17 hours.
Excellent.
Special thanks to Taka and Dragonbane for helping my research with this video. I'm gymnast86 and thank you for watching.
Die machen echt nice Videos. Wenn man sich ein bisschen für speedrunning-Sachen interessiert, find ich die echt gut.
Ich überlege gerade, ob ich jetzt schon was zu essen mache, weil ich habe übelst Hunger.
Ich habe auch nichts gefrühstückt heute.
Und nachdem die YouTube-Empfehlung auch so richtig sacken.
Five Mistakes New Programmers Make.
Tja. Was sind die fünf größte Fehler, die neue Programmierer machen?
Ich würde sagen, sich zu viele Gedanken machen. Der hauptsächliche Fehler ist eigentlich, sich zu viele Gedanken zu machen und vor allem daran zu zweifeln, dass man das irgendwie hinkriegt.
Nach dem Motto, es ist viel zu kompliziert, ich weiß nicht, wo ich anfangen soll. Aber ansonsten, was sind die größten Noob? Die falsche Sprache zum Einstieg nehmen vielleicht.
Also mit so einem Kack wie C++ anzufangen zum Beispiel.
Aber ich glaube, das größte Problem ist, dass die Leute sich am Anfang viel zu viele Gedanken machen, ohne einfach mal ein bisschen auszuprobieren.
Weil viele Sachen kriegt man erst im Kopf sortiert, wenn man sie schon mal gemacht hat. Und dann kommt man auch besser auf Lösungen.
Ne Redstar OS ist übelst langweilig, gucken wir uns nicht an.
Copy Paste, ohne zu verstehen. Ja, das sind aber Noobs, die ihn eigentlich nicht programmieren lernen wollen.
Zum Beispiel unser einer Spezial Azubi, der Shit, der der Git Shit ausgesprochen hat, das war auch so einer, der hat den ganzen Tag Stack Overflow programmiert.
Ich hab zu ihm gesagt, er soll mal einen.NET, also einen C Sharp, BMI Rechner machen. Ich weiß, BMI Rechner ist halt übelst easy.
Das ist so eines der Standardübungs Sachen, die man vom Anfang an macht.
Bitte geben sie ihre Größe ein, bitte geben sie ihr Gewicht ein. Theoretisch kann man auch einen geben, bitte geben sie ihr Geschlecht und Alter ein oder was auch immer.
Oh Alter, sorry, geben sie nur ihr Alter ein. Oder Alter, ist Alter noch okay? Darf man Alter noch sagen?
Weiß nicht, kommt bestimmt auch noch irgendwann. Alter geht auch nicht mehr.
So, das hat er dann gebastelt und er hat sich wirklich die Hälfte aus Stack Overflow zusammen kopiert.
Und irgendwann kam er dann zu mir und meinte, Max, Max, es geht, es geht.
Da hab ich mir das angeguckt und hab mir gedacht, hm, also es kompiliert, aber gehen tut es nicht.
Da war auch der Meinung, es kompiliert, es startet, es muss gehen.
Okay Leute, wisst ihr was? Wir spielen nachher noch eine Runde Battlefield im Stream.
Ich geh mir jetzt schon was zu essen machen, ich hab übelst Hunger.
Ich hoffe, wir sind schon wach, wir sind bisschen früher fertig als sonst.
Aber wir haben heute auch ein bisschen früher angefangen.
Nachher spielen wir noch eine Runde Battlefield. Wir sehen uns Leute, bis später.
Bis zum nächsten Mal, ciao.